à ce nouveau stream et ce nouveau match
de ce pitch est championship donc c'est
un nouveau match du premier tour qui va
opposer le grand favori d'après moi
enfin l'un des grands favoris du speech
s sergueï kaliakine à
jan christoph dude raconte qu'on va
appeler en fait jean christophe au final
il y en a marre des noms polonais c'est
trop compliqué jan christoph on n'arrive
pas à le prononcer donc jean christophe
tu as voulu prendre un nom français bon
bah voilà tiré tuant un prénom français
et empire c'est comme ça c'est la vie et
meiwey jan christoph duda donc qui est
un jeune joueur polonais âgé d'une
vingtaine d'années et qui est classée
2739 fils
donc il n'est pas si loin au classement
fit de karuïa qui me doit y avoir avec
le nouveau classement une vingtaine de
points d'écart 20,25 points d'écart au
classement film peut-être plus tôt 25 30
mai mais y'a pas une si grande
différence que ça mais bon c'est des
joueurs qui sont entre guillemets d'une
autre d'une autre galaxie en duda qui
est quand même un très jeune joueur qui
a peut-être un avenir très radieux
devant lui qui va peut-être monte monte
monte monte monte monte jusque jusqu'au
titre de champion du monde même qui sait
c'est possible mais mes bons sergei k
reen la différence est que l'huile titre
de champion du monde il a failli déjà le
remporter en partie longue puisqu'il
avait joué le fameux match contre 40
scènes il ya deux ans maintenant et il a
déjà été champion du monde de blitz en
donc bon ça a marqué plus que confirmer
car yakine ou plus haut niveau en partie
longue mais aussi en blitz
donc ça semble être un match assez
déséquilibré mais il y a un
lien mais à mon avis en tout cas c'est
que kariya qui n'a pas été en forme à
l'asim que phil cup il a dit qu'il avait
perdu du poids
je crois qu'il ait perdu du poids et qu'
il n'était pas ça l'a empêché d'être
dans une forme optimale et donc qui c
est ce que ça peut jouer j'y crois pas
personnellement je veux pas vous vendre
du rêve
moi j'y crois pas moi je pense que ça va
être un match à sens unique et que
cariat keane va juste l'exploser façon
puzzle et que et que 12 heures va pas
faire un pli mais voilà pour pour
essayer de mettre un petit peu de piment
à ce match
bon je vais quand même souligner ce
point qui est qui à mon avis le seul
point noir sur sur le tableau de karuïa
qui je vais suivre les joueurs absolvent
arriver incessamment sous peu on a fait
les réglages il est juste parti faire un
petit à petit je sais pas comment faire
cette phrase mais mais il va bientôt
arriver et il va arriver d'ici d'ici
deux trois minutes
eh bien on va pouvoir se lancer dans le
match les joueurs n'ont pas encore
commencé moi je vais faire un petit
tweet on est parti pour le match car
yakine duda et je vais mettre là le lion
de l'adresse http s de points cela slash
peut doubler doué pointe which point tv
slash chaise com fr ça va y aller lâche
chaise com/fr up et je vais faire le
petit hashtag échec
et on va être bon donc comme ça le tout
était fait le facebook j'avais fait plus
tôt n'hésitez pas à partager un
d'ailleurs ok donc le match à lui match
est parti et donc absents peuvent
arriver d'ici d'une minute à l'autre
donc eu 4 c 5 une sirène pour commencer
des six des quatre ok donc déjà
intéressant l'ouverture on a une
sicilienne ouverte une nage daf donc ça
fait plaisir si ça continue
si ça va là dedans c'est cool ainsi on
se prend des nageurs de partout on n'est
pas contre donc il a joué avant tech
fund 2,5 et b3 donc la très important
c'est le combat pour la casse des 5es
hockey à g4 donc là j'ai quatre c'est
une double idée d'un premier côté
car yakine il envoie le pion j'ai donc
bon déjà automatiquement un bon coup un
ver le roi mais surtout il omet le pion
au g5 pourquoi pour attaquer le cavalier
et gagner la case des cinq plaqués et 17
ans maintenant est ce qu'on fait dam des
deux avec qui des grands rock pour bien
consolider la case des cinq est cachée
droit et après envoyé les pions sur le
roi noir ça paraît assez logique et
assez à ces gens à venir
assez assez standard comme plan b si
donc le cavalier qui vient recontrôler
la case des 5 et qui s'approche de la
case éventuellement c4 qui a aidé 5 qui
est peut-être qu'il va prendre prendre
et faire flouer f5 qui est une manière
classique de jouer à noter qu'ils
menaçaient peut-être des cinq aussi avec
les avec les noirs reste quand même
assez standard de prendre et de faire
flouer 5 mais peut-être qu'il ya
d'autres choses à faire plus plus
intéressante pour les noirs bon il ya
quand même une menace blanche c'est fou
prend v6 à farrou cavaliers prend b6
donc il faut il faut réagir à cette
menace
parce que prendre du fou ça aurait
laissé les cases blanches donc voilà
c'est ce qui vient d'être joué mais donc
assez logique le fou de cases blanches
qui vient défendre h7 et réattaquer ses
dehors il est bien placé se fout il
défend les droits et a taclé la dame f4
donc les blancs prennent de l'espace a
les droits et cavaliers 17 dont qui se
prépare à regagner la case 5 avec le
cavalier quand elle sera libérée et 17
peut-être grand roque maintenant un jour
ou l'autre quand même laissé soit au
centre
bon il peut laisser au centre après un
mais je vois pas trop ce qui peut faire
de plus intéressant de grand roque mes
grands qui va se prendre pour ces huit
mentions qui prend une première fois au
sein qu'avant écoutez j'aime bien la
position de duda perso police fighter
j'ai envie de te dire 3 me dont on ne
sait pas pourquoi d'ailleurs bien que
déjà la police peut-être tut tut tut tut
poli quoi bon tour f1 j'imagine fou g6
on imagine et après la confiance et du
talent fou et 4 x 4 un coût qui à mon
avis est plus ambitieux parce que là il
vient taper un peu des saints qui vient
contre la case f3 il vient préparer tour
ses huit peut-être plus ambitieux que
tour g8 et finalement ce fou et ce qui
peut vraiment être attaqué oui bon la
réponse est oui partout rêve 4 mai la
tour est moins bien placés en f4 puisque
le pion le pion fait 5 était menacée
mais les blancs soutiennent par h4 avec
l'idée de faire h5 et de s'en prendre
aux fous on imagine un petit coup de
tours c'est 8 ça mange pas de pain j'ai
pas mis le bon lien twitch surtout sur
ton switch
ah non c'est pas fait exprès sur mon
twitter c'est pas fait exprès c'est pas
fait exprès il faut que je modifie et je
peux pas modifié c'est pas fait exprès
tout ce que j'ai fait avec l'ordinateur
et donc avec le téléphone est donc j'ai
raté et je vais faut que joe smash
aimerait tout à fait de l'hostie machine
twitch au passage c'est vrai que c'est
pas idiot
hop comme ça c est comme ça c'est fait
donc l'hermine cam à néant dès 4 h 5
c'est pour éviter donc à y ait des cas
c'est pour protéger de pioncer 2 h 5
c'est pour éviter f5 bien évidemment
j'ai envie de dire je vais en profiter
pour refaire mon petit tweet au passage
donc mais pour protéger une petite
seconde les tontons je vais être de
retour face on a le temps il va y avoir
trois heures de match
donc j'ai envie de dire j'ai envie on a
le temps de se mettre en place
on a le temps de se mettre en place pour
ce match donc b3 marc b3 j'imagine qu'il
veut jouer ces quatre pages sépaq
imagine c'est que j'en suis sûr
plus ou moins en skaï provenant il
contrôle aussi la casse etc a peut-être
fait pas jouer ces quatre peut-être
empêché aussi il veut peut-être aussi
empêché
ces quatre de la part qu'elle s'écarte
de la part des noirs quant à la partie
et faire le fr le tweet en même temps
c'est pas c'est pas un truc le plus
facile du monde mais c'est vrai que le
fr en fait il n'a pas pris tout à
l'heure et au thé soit si j'imagine que
c'est le bon et on va pouvoir repartir
pour la partie du hockey
donc grand roque quand même joué
finalement est fou dès 8h food et 8,5
plan classique qui veut repasser le fou
vers la case b6 attaqué un petit peu le
fou et 3 et éventuellement venir aussi
vert vert à 5 pour attaquer la dame
possible il revient vers b6 il s'en
prend aux aux cavaliers on verra cinq
moments c'était difficile hein mais
qu'est-ce et parfois ça aurait pu être
possible mais les images du coup prend
des 4 et tout repenser de a donc avalé
f5
il enlève le cavalier il couvre la casse
ces deux et il vient s'en prendre au roi
noir
donc ça pas mal et il s'en prend aussi
aux poupées 6 au passage comment est ce
que tout ça va réagir guillemine
lecavalier donc pris deux reprises il
élimine le fou gsis mais envoie enfin
moi j'aime bien les noirs encore un
parce que lecavalier
si vous comparez en fait le cavalier e 5
au fouet eux deux on voit que le
cavalier ils payent les tentaculaires
ici le feu de il a pas vraiment de
bonnes cases et le cavalier tentaculaire
après il y défend le pion à vii aussi
ces graines hyper important après il
faut avouer que il peut y avoir des
idées de fou prend 1,5 à un moment donné
mais j'y crois pas du tout parce que
quand bien même on serait même pas
obligé de prendre
et là c'est vrai que les noirs veut
jouer tour c86 une pions violence et 4
on va pouvoir faire b5 on va ouvrir à
fond et les blancs vont vont être
bloqués à la défense de ce tueur alors
après il va encore falloir travailler
pour vraiment faire quelque chose mais
genre même des cinq des quatre tours ces
trois peut-être mettre une tour ans et 3
passes et la dame vera faire tour ses
cinq tours à 5 face à peut être des
plans après c'est dur à mettre en place
voilà juste ce pion au saint des saints
qui était en l'air mais est ce que c'est
une si bonne idée de prendre le pion des
cinq continents étaient peut-être pas si
utile que ça et ça permet aux blancs de
trouver du contre
je peut-être ben je sais pas après j'ai
évidemment les joueurs voient mieux que
moi mais peut-être joué b5 et à et
hockey à voir
à voir ce que sur des saints qui a pu en
fait le truc c'est que si des six tombes
en fait le cavalier e 5 person son son
appui quoi donc est ce cette tour lancé
si surtout pas parce que la dame prend
2,5 donc dams est ok alors l'idée c'est
qu'ils menacent qu'ils aient pensé 4
avec avec la découverte sur la dame
mesdames d2 il se décale hippie ils
menacent maintenant le pion des six
alors est ce qui menace plutôt dame
prend des 6 août où reprend je ne sais
pas mais il remet menace des six et ils
le menacent trois fois donc ça fait même
s'ils protègent des six parades mettons
tout retour c6 on peut quand même
prendre ce qu'on défendra que deux fois
bon
c'est dangereux dessins qu'ils envoient
le contre dame prend des 6000 ya tout
qui va ce liquide et savas liquidée en
c4 et on peut rester avec le pion le
pion h quatre ans prix si on liquide
sert c'est avec les blancs on avait
décidé d'aller prendre ces cas de
prendre tout prendre c'est 4 on aurait
pu se retrouver dans le problème et
c'est pour ça que s'y prend c4 qui prend
ses 4 il fera surtout pas fou prend pas
ce qu'il veut pas perdre h4 donc tour
des saints qui s'en prend aux cavaliers
c'est bien joué et le cavalier qui a
perdu son socle où est le socle dont on
parlait tout à l'heure en deux pions des
six n'est plus là et l'idée c'est que si
lecavalier s'en va on va vouloir retaper
le pion c4 et peut-être même qu'on va
être mieux avec les blancs pascal pion à
600 l'air bon ces trois jouets et
cavaliers c6 nos pains en menace
cavaliers des quatre échecs pour faire
une fourchette à 3 évite cavaliers des
quatre cavaliers e set et il se redirige
vers la case f5 qui va avoir un nouveau
socle et il menacera de s'en prendre aux
pions h4 et peut-être aussi tous les
cavaliers trois échecs mais le truc
c'est cavaliers aux trois échecs on sera
en diagonale par rapport à la casse
c'est un on aura du mal à venir
dame est donc très bien joué de la part
de karuïa kinky mais la tour en 17 et le
fou en c4 donc il a fait une double
action sur le pion à vii et il empêche
ils empêchent ils enlèvent la protection
du pion c3 donc bouffe h4 et on va
bouffer à vii sur échec j'imagine et
peut-être un petit coup de tours f6 qui
va quoique touristes tour c5
il fait faux bond à 6 ou et bien joué
ils attaquent la tour je pense être
mieux bien mieux joué que je proposais
tour c5 ou pas n'ont pas joué donc là
maintenant peut-être touré fils
mais attention parce qu'à ce pion là qui
file aussi adam c'est hyper compliqué
les mecs il a fait tous rêvent 6,3 g 7
il va faire du a4 maintenant préparer
fou bessette le four est impérial ou fou
des trois cas qui a valu aux trois
chèques pas prendre ces trois y aura
qu'à et d5 attention on croit prend ces
trois en premier je pense que c'est bien
joué le pion à chf il fouet fin défend
tout mais car les kings qui ont envoyé
le pion à il est peut-être gagnant et on
à l'arrivée dab sol salut absolvent you
pourquoi je te vois pas où je vais
peut-être le partage d'écran t'as pas
raté grand chose en train de regarder la
première partie du cours la tension ce
que j'avais dit dès 30 ares se fera donc
écoute c'est la première partie est ce
que tu as un favori pour ce match
institué le polonais contre quel pays
bruisse russe serait allé moi je suis
toujours content sophie ont conduit
qu'il va perdre donc le polonais pour le
polonais écoute ça démarre pas très bien
savate avoué parce que donc là tu vois
mon écran on est d'accord
ouais je vois ton partage d'écran tu vas
mon partage d'écran donc avec les blancs
takhar yakine ah oui donc là c'est mort
ouais ouais après regarde il a quand
même pas rien peut-être une fourchette
avec le cavalier ou enfin ce niveau là
tu te fais pas avoir par une fourche
haute comme normalement non mais bon tu
sais ça arrive à tout le monde
ce détroit trois minutes nos sorties cd
cinq minutes pour le moment passé les
cinq minutes
[ __ ] c'est fini non il peut prendre
battus à s'y prend là je pense que
l'autre euros voulait reprendre le fou
et protégez moi j'aurais pris le pion si
l'on va voir
23 c'est pas si facile d'organiser avec
les vins ces gagnants mais c'est par wes
de fond bien c'est pas si simple à
réaliser
ok là c'est pas mal ce qu'il a fait
parce que les noirs ils sont tombés
coeur et son look et ray et il a
abandonné
enfin il a perdu au nom il menacé
m'attendais donc déjà 1 0 écoute ça
commence bien
pas ça commence bien le favori diane
comme doc
sans surprise ouais mais c'est dur il ya
beaucoup de parties du coup ils sont
cons ils sont contre leurs lots du coup
c'est bien alors karim je peux te dire
ça j'ai jeté un oeil le polonais et les
deux mille sept cent trente neuf
je prends pas si on ne sait pas encore
quand je parle sur way sur sur hello
officiel je vais dire ça tout de suite
cariat qui il est 14e mondial en ce
moment il est 2760 et
et d'oudaï les 23e mondiale et il est
2739 donc 2560 s'est déjà mis non web à
partir de 2005 tg après maison qui sont
là il faut faire un nouveau faudrait
faire un nouveau titre mais mais si tu
veux la grosse différence c'est surtout
une différence de deux classes entre
guillemets si tu veux parce que car
yakine pas peut-être est-ce que tu
jouais déjà aux échecs quand il ya eu le
match 45 arias qui nous pas mais à moi
je crois bien qu'on avait commenté un
match cardiokine non bon alors même ma
mémoire me fait défaut mais l'an dernier
mais comment terme match avec le mée
match pour le titre de champion du monde
il ya deux ans tu jouais pas encore aux
échecs non je m'intéresse pas aux
joueurs de choc en tout cas et donc la
fête ils allaient jouer il ya deux ans
et lui s'étaient qualifiés pour jouer
contre carl scène pour le titre de
champion du monde
du coup ça finit comment ça a fini à 6
partout à wilton de crise il voient pas
ils ont fait dit il on fait 10 nuls et
une victoire chacun ah ouais et ça s'est
fini non partie rapide ou car le sel l'a
emporté en départage
il a fallu finir sur le tour du monde du
coup ah ouais bah ils étaient ils
étaient allés tenir un match nul en fait
parce qu'ils menaient dans le match
ils menaient
5-4 et à la 10e partie car le scène il a
égalisé ils s'en sortent toujours lu un
seul croyable fort aussi c'est pour ça
mais alors il est plus fort à chaque
fois j'ai l'impression qui s'en sort
toujours de justesse quoi ouais mais bon
parce qu'il est plus fort ils sont sans
rage quant à l'effet tour match contre
lui tu étais en train de mener je crois
bien c'est le temps où je ne sais quoi
qui a fait que ça a été gâté non
wes parce que j'avais plus assez de
temps pour réussir à finir
donc tu vois encore une fois il s'était
bien de la chance je sais pas si on peut
appeler ça de la chance c'est le talent
c'est ce qui te met la pression tout le
temps non tu es obligé de thé obligé de
plus réfléchir et
il a de la marge est ce que tu sais
contre qui va jouer cette année
d'ailleurs
carn carlson pour le titre de champion
du monde spike désolant piège
non il va alors été bourré moi j'attends
toujours ce match là on chante tour du
monde ouais ouais
depuis qu'il a pu participer au tournoi
il n'avait pas pu participer au tour un
des candidats
d'ailleurs j'étais chez toi quand il
s'était pas qualifié la déception se
lisait sur son visage
ouais c'était chiant et du coup c'est
caruana c'est un joueur américain qui
s'est qualifié je lui ai également
commente avec toi car mandat ouais je
pense que c'est les deux qu'on avait
fait on avait fait caruana ha yakine oui
on avait fait deux matches différents
mondes de feu et du coup et ça a duré
pas loin de chez toi ce match d'ailleurs
pour le titre ah oui où ça ça va jouer à
londres
paulhan de chez moi aujourd'hui ouais
t'as quoi ta ta ta 1h02 je croyais que
tu as lire je croyais que tu allais dire
didier pour un truc comme ça
ouais ou par y arriver mais londres a
c'est pas super mais enfin si tu veux tu
peux y aller coiffure c'est faisable
ça fait deux ou trois heures 3 4 passes
en soit je suis plus proche de londres
que de toi ouais en soirée et moi aussi
quelques parce que c'est plus facile
d'aller en avion à londres que de venir
jusque chez toi quelque part en temps
mais du coup en fait le truc c'est que
ces matches là on aura puis on a un tous
les dix ans en fait des matches comme ça
pour le titre de champion du monde donc
ça peut valoir le coup d'aller voir
honnêtement je veux dire si on place
ouais carrément à mais c'est hyper rare
enfin peut-être tu vois que ça enfin
puisque taux différents championnats du
monde en fait c'est vrai ces matchs
match pour le titre de champion du monde
eh bah c'est pas tous les ans c'est tous
les deux ans ouais là tu me dis que
c'est tous les dix on pourra en europe
je veux dire en europe de corps en
europe sert à ça si tu comptes pas la
russie comme l'europe
bon même si c'est l'europe
biographiquement mais bon
on va dire que c'est plus difficile
d'aller en russie que d'aller en
angleterre quand même mes proches de
chez nous en fait c'est fin c'est très
très rare
là les derniers matchs et ils ont eu
lieu à new york donc aux états unis
sotchi en russie
chennai en inde je croire moscou il ya
huit ans que j'étais allé le voir il ya
dix ans je me rappelle plus mais c'était
peut-être c'était peut-être en bulgarie
ah ouais là il ya vingt ans sur le chat
qui dit il y a eu un grand open d'échecs
adia pickass de semaine ouais c'est pour
ça que justement je citais dieppe ce
qu'il ya beaucoup de tournois d'échecs
international même parfois à dire c'est
un grand rassemblement je sais pas si tu
connais dieppe
ouais je connais je connais et ben à
dire que j'y suis il ya ça une heure
chez moi donc et arrivant le tournoi ou
pas ouais j'y suis allé jeter un coup
d'oeil mais j'ai pas pu rentrer dans la
salle même mais juste pour voir un petit
peu
pourquoi tape à travers les fenêtres a
pu rentrer dans la saleté était qu'on ne
pouvait pas entrer dans la salle tout
simplement sérieux moi j'ai trouvé ça
normal
imaginer n'importe qui peut rentrer
déconcentrer les joueurs abba d'habitude
ff à n'importer vendent à n'importe qui
rentrait par contre j'ai fait des
tournois de schalk à dire tu as fait un
tournoi d'échecs
ouais mais tu avais pas dit ça débutant
c'est parce qu'il ya il ya même un club
de duchess boxing d'adiaké bon ça c'est
le mec qui font de boxe et je sais qu'en
même temps ça je me sentirais pas trop
favorite voix et du coup c'est pas ça
s'est passé comment pour toi c'est parti
je les ai gagnés je suis arrivé en
finale et j'ai battu lugano
ok donc tu as gagné ouais enfin j'ai
gagné quoi un 1er mai c'était débutants
débutants c'était c'était un club
d'échecs organisé ça avec ses adhérents
et moi je ne faisais pas du tout partie
du club en fait et je lui ai demandé si
c'était possible quand même de
participer m'a dit ok et ça t'a donné
envie de te voir de battre des joueurs
qui ont fait dès qu'on re su des cours
d'échecs quoi alors que moi aujourd'hui
a reçu aucun ouais mais après tu joues
beaucoup et puis ça avec la pratique
aussi
ouais enfin comme je te disais juste
avant le live moi j'ai beaucoup régressé
sept ans il ya qu'à voir mes parties sur
deux chez ce point comme lost c'est une
horreur tout le monde te battre n
importe qui je me fais battre par des
955 958 m ois me suis pas concentrée
mais tu laisses des pièces en un coup tu
fais tu fais n'importe quoi
ceux des manques d'une attention et
c'est que tu donnes des trucs en un coup
tout le temps pas souvent badis donc en
fait je fais que du 5-5 donc parfois il
ya marraine qui part je n'ai pas vu tout
ça écrit tu devrais cayenne mon parfum
de parfois des échanges de pièces qui
sont pas avantageux pour moi que je
crois qu'à la fin mais tu devrais donc
voila tu dragues l'histoire de ma vie
j'aimerais quand même monté jusqu'à 1200
à mon avis en 1152 sans visa par contre
en partie 15 10 je dois être aux
alentours de 1350 parce que là j'ai plus
le temps de réfléchir tu vois ok donc et
c'est peut-être pas vraiment à régresser
c'est peut-être que tu as du mal à jouer
en cinq 5 miles de ça j'ai pas le temps
de réfléchir
je pense que ceux qui jouent bien en 5 5
c'est parce que c'est que des réflexes
pour eux tu vois des échecs ils ont plus
meilleur effet l'actuel armand mais du
coup pourquoi tu joues que rend 5,5 par
manque de temps ou pas - je peux
attendre faire deux parties en 15 10
tata yoyo qui dit qui joue lui en dix
minutes + 0 les gens disent + 0 est très
heureux moi je fais jamais des parties
où il n'y a pas un plus quelque chose n
aime pas qu on te fait quand on te fait
tomber je me rappelle ça tenait même
mois la moitié de mes parties je les
perds à cause du temps quand bien même
je mène parfois le mec il a plus que son
roi j'ai eu avec ma reine d'autres trucs
et j'arrive pas à le mettre échec et
gagne autant je suis dégoûté ouais mais
j'ai vu ça j'ai vu quand t'as joué
contre y penser j'ai regardé
attentivement les parties et j'ai vu que
tu avais un peu de mal à
as a matter en fait à la fin ah bah moi
les fins de [ __ ] c'est une horreur
ouais j'ai remarqué il se planquer avec
son roi et tu réussissais pas vraiment
être efficace pour le maté rapidement
bah je faisais surtout attention de le
palmpad parce que ça m'arrive aussi
souvent n était pas loin d'ailleurs dans
une partie fans s'étaient pas loin sa
contrôlée mais ça aurait pu m'arriver je
son droit là parce que s'ils n'avaient
pas bougé son roi le ram il fou en f4 et
il prenait la tour de verre avec dans la
partie là qu'on est en train de regarder
ouais ouais mais la nature il va envoyer
le pion skrela sont rois ils étaient
entre 3 il mettait le fou en f4 j'ai
dégagé il prenait la tour qui était en
ceci cela c'est pour ça qu'il est parti
avec la tour en fait c'est pour ça qu'il
a bouclée droit je reste mais je vois
plus le chat par contre il à moi non
plus l'air comme ça enfin j'essaie de
bien organiser l'écran pour qu'on a un
peu tout ce temps là on le voit ce match
comme ça comme ça on a bien le on a on a
tous on a tous à l'écran souffle aux
caméras saf les caméras mais bon c'est
pas très grave
on le voit toi ouais on voit on le voit
on voit tout le monde moi je voulais
faire je te vois même pas je me vois
même pas moi donc non centre voit pas
mais on voit le pas de face on est quand
même plus en plus concentrée sur
l'échiquier
oui mais tu vois là le truc intéressant
c'est que
ouah c'est joli ça cif et dames il va
faire échec
le roi va être obligé de revenir sur
cette colonne là il va refaire échec et
bavois loupé la dame derrière donc ça
veut dire que à moins qu'ils aient un
truc qu'on voit pas ça veut dire que le
polonais va égaliser
peut-être pas sûr parce que du coup il
va monter son roi comme ça il va faire
ça il va aussi mais là la tour en a un
il va apprendre le prends comme s'il
faisait au coude avant il perdait aussi
en fait différents différemment mais
voilà du coup il reste avec un pion
enfin une pièce de plus et voilà c'est
facile à gagner avec les blancs ça c'est
élémentaire touquet les blonds là c'est
le polonais donc leymen la voile et il
va il va gagner c'est sûr il ya
d'ailleurs eu abandon une pièce de plus
c'est beaucoup trop asti voilà donc un
partout et ça va être ça fait de nouveau
une ouverture sicile année ce que ça
tarifs ont en partie contre tous à la
sicilienne sur 4 complètent le clan ses
cinq jeux je déteste cette cette
ouverture j'arrive jamais à la contrer
ouais tu te fais tu sais marcher dessus
a beau tout le temps au temps bah moi je
le fais toujours mon e 5 e 4 tout le
temps connaît rien d'autre alors les
mecs te font ces cinq mois vous vous
inspire toi parce qu'il va y en avoir
beaucoup aujourd'hui des sicilienne je
pense qu'on va revoir à toutes les
parties la mêlée intro et de joutes
allemand 8 moucheron pour renault ouais
mais ça tu verras si on n'envoie pas mal
ça peut donner des idées
bon là ce qui se passe tu vois c'est que
ce qu'on a peur et c'est un genre de
structure mahrouk sinon tu dois pas
connaître mais c'est une structure de
pions un peu étrange parce que
d'habitude quand on joue ses positions
là il ya un puits en c4 un pion à 7
et là ils ont été échangés donc ça
change quelques petits trucs et là
l'idée des blancs c'est que tu as ils
ont un grand avantage des spas situation
se fait une ligne
là tu vois enfin tuer les blancs ils ont
plus d'espacé que les noirs
elles sont plus développées en fait ça
c'est du tu vois regarde option qui est
l'arc à tokyo en d6 tu atteins le pion
d66 et plus reculé que le pion aux 4
donc en fait sacrer cette sacrée cette
frontière et ça fait que les blancs plus
d'espacé pour leurs pièces
ils sont faux qui rayonne sur
l'échiquier comme se dit les deux en
plus quelques parties enfin le faux en 3
est quand même bien plus haut ouais ce
qui fait un genre de double emploi avec
les pions quoi pas les pions qui sont
sur blanc qui contrôle ça est attablé
qui contrôle ça m'est à lui qui peut
aussi se le fou de deux cases noires des
noirs il peut aussi faire les deux
peuvent rayonner en fait voilà ils
menacent une fourchette
je sais que ça te faire plaisir j'adore
et fourchettes ont attaqué les deux
tours avant de téléphone des fourchettes
maintenant je suis encore plus plus fun
quand j'arrive à faire des clous annoncé
les clous non j'adore les couloirs en ce
moment j'ai mes petites périodes avec
l'âge c'est une peu plus bouger tapiès
allait clouer way où tu sais quand par
exemple le roi ils ont ensuite il a ses
trois plombs devant que tu mets un fou
par exemple en alchimie éclats d'âme et
sur la colonne je ne peux pas te prendre
tu vois comme ça tu m'as temps de l'es7
après voilà c'est ce que j'avais voulu
faire la bruce d'ailleurs dans la
deuxième partie mais elle a réussi à
dévier tricks et avait donné du matériel
non pour les réguliers un truc du
matériel mais il progresse boussou pas
en fait on ne sait pas non lui il est
comme moi ils jouent sans progresser
quoi joue me sens à prendre mais toi tu
tintin tintin désir d'apprendre ou pas
en fait en réalité où tu veux jouer
comme ça où tu aimerais quand même bien
être plus fort bah moi j'aimerais bien
apprendre mais j'ai pas le temps je sais
il ya beaucoup de choses que j'aimerais
faire dans la vie mais j'ai pas le temps
de le faire
les merdes moi ce sera un truc dont on
aurait enfin tu aurais vraiment envie ou
bon
exit fait quand même a clairement voir
comment dire constater que j'ai
progressé en battant des joueurs que
j'aurais jamais battu avant elle ce sera
un réel plaisir tu vois après le fait
d'apprendre en soi un bon je trouve ça
chiant à prendre mais c'est toujours ça
fait toujours plaisir de voir que tu as
pourrait s'être tu serais plutôt pour
progresser que pour apprendre encore
laurent soir les deux sont obligatoires
est-ce que tu as il m'arrive d'avoir des
élèves
ils viennent machin et ils ont plus
envie d'apprendre que de progresser en
fait ils disent ouais moi je m'en fous
si je gagne des lots ou pas ou tu veux
pas décevoir plus force les intéressent
paris veulent juste mieux comprendre les
échecs en fait ouais mais moi j'ai pas
envie de le comprendre partir deux
ouvertures par exemple tu vois ça ne
m'intéresse pas ouais mais tape
oui mais tu as quand même beaucoup de
choses à au delà des ouvertures
énormément de choses à apprendre
vraiment il mange quoi comme pizza
quatre fromages
c'est du coup c'est pas vegan ce
pavilion normes et les pas de joindre du
coup un cv ya des mecs que je l'état
lien même non non je dis des conneries
que j'ai tant rien excuser moi c'est toi
le spécialiste ça fait là tu as fait ta
fameuse vidéo
enfin ça fait même plusieurs absolu ce
type de jeu à rêver j'ai amis bon déjà
c'est j'arrive à dépasser les 1500
surtout comme ce sera un miracle au
caire et a du coup des petits enfants
adorent 1500 c'est un objectif et a
quand même lâché un lots comme ça la tat
lâché un nombre de points
bah dis donc tu sais que quand tu
t'inscris sur ce point comme tu
commences par un truc de départ wilton
un caleçon à des 1500 noms précis près
donc moi j'ai commencé à 1500 j'ai
jamais dépassé les 1500 j'ai toujours
reculer tu vois quand j'ai commencé ma
première partie moi je me souviens il
faudrait un jour que je retourne sur ce
point de départ là au moins tu vois ça
voudra dire que j'aurais pu être pas
marqué mais cette fois ci paraît si tu
travailles et où c'est possible mais bon
c'était pas le temps on n'a pas le temps
mais tu es pris par tes projets par
partez partez projet youtube tout ce à
quoi bon et j'ai trente six mille trucs
à faire j'ai mon boulot à temps plein
donc je suis de tous les soirs à 19h
j'ai mes vidéos je sais pas les petites
vidéos à chaque fois
il ya des nouveaux trucs qui vont qui
sortent là tu as des stades et des
enfants nous lâcher là en ce moment je
suis en train de travailler la
logistique sur la bd là donc ça prend du
temps aussi vu qu'elle est partie à
l'impression faut contacter tout le
monde n'est pas si compliqué j'étais
pâmé détails j'ai aussi un livre en
cours d'écriture donc enfin tout ça ça
prend énormément de temps battus en a
parlé du bouquin ah bon ouais vas
peut-être je sais plus à qui j'en parle
pas ici si tu en a parlé mais il a après
un road to yami fait un rod 1500 avec
l'aps c'est vrai qu'on avait parlé du
veulent une sorte de blog de toi et
qu'il monte jusqu'à tu l'a jamais fait
non plus à mai
mais en fait j'ai enfin rien mais qui
vient de faire sur sur la chaîne
bitstream un copain qui lui fait un vrai
rouge amis donc on a vraiment une série
comme ça on suit vraiment un mec qui
essaye de le faire mais mais bon pour le
mans fin on n'est qu'au début la c'est
ça prend des années un ce2 les 2400 là
pour le moment ah oui le boss de
politiques mondiaux mais que mais il
fait re dropt du coup certes ou 2500
tours ils veulent te faire faire le roda
1500 tu vois c'est déjà plus faisable en
trois parties je peux être en mixant son
je pense dames on pourrait y arriver il
faut forer combat si on veut c'est
régulièrement pourrait le faire je
pourrais aider à faire ce que ferait
beau s'est régulièrement fait beau c'est
une fois par semaine pendant un an
bon combien d'heures par semaine
enfin qu'on fasse une deux heures
ensemble et que tu bosses de ton côté
encore trois heures par semaine
peut-être moi donc cinq heures par
semaine cinq heures par semaine arrive à
les placer son coeur en plus c'est cinq
vrais heures tu vois c'est pas pas
construit dès 5h ces cinq heures
intensives c'est pas à 5 heures où tu es
tu vois voilà donc tu comptes plus quoi
il tombe se concentrer tout ça ma vraie
à j 4 5 et enfin à dire que si tu fais
cinq heures en valeur plus ou moins bien
mais qui en vaut se fait 4 heures
vraiment intensive et 5 heures en tout
mais oui mais non mais c'est dur pas
mais bon tu peux faire un nageur ses
1500 tu peux y arriver quoi un jour
c'est sûr quand je serai à la retraite
jean lte en larmes et orale temps avant
peut-être un jour on aura peut-être par
de faire autant vider autant de trucs
non quand on sera devenu un mortel grâce
aux progrès de la médecine
on en a tous notre temps tu penses ce
serait une bonne chose
bah oui mais j'ai envie de jouer pour
but de mourir moi ça pas peur de
s'ennuyer à force après si je m'ennuie
je me tue depuis voilà sur cette
solution mais il faudra rester jeunes
aussi techniquement si on arrive à
changer tout ce qui est elle au maire
tout ça sa cellule elle se régénère et
de tout en jaune
ouais non mais ce serait possible mais
bon j'ai peur qu'on vit dans un monde
vraiment horrible si c'était le cas il y
aurait pas d'enfant n'aurait toujours la
même génération tout le temps aidant les
gens n'auraient plus d'enfants est vrai
que les mêmes gens et je pense que le
monde deviendrait iprp revers l'aurait
pas d'innovation veut que y'a que les
jeunes qu'ils font à l'innovation
les nouvelles idées mais ce sera un
monde très triste en fait est ce que
notre monde est pas déjà triste vous
êtes sur le live de la déprime
ouais
c'est badens est un jour fc bas non non
mais je n'ai pas l'immortalité c'est pas
un truc qui me tim quand tu vois ce mois
je me suis toujours dit tu vois c'est
comme le mec qui est mort juste avant
que la guerre se finit le dernier mort
d'une guerre c'était quand même le plus
mal chance du monde
ouais et bas eh ben je me dis la même
chose pour quand on trouvera un entre
guillemets remède pour l'immortalité
je me dis le dernier mec qui mourra une
fois qu'on aura injecté tout le remède à
tout le monde pour l'immortalité
c'est quand même le plus malchanceux de
l'histoire de l'humanité mais on en est
on en est proche de ce truc là toi qui
te renseignes plus sur ces sujets là au
niveau de la médecine
on s'approche de ce genre de choses
n'ont pas tout de suite bon du coup nous
on ne verra pas de toute façon banon ok
donc on peut mourir tranquille en gros
on va pas se dire on est malchanceux
savent à quoi on risque pas d'être le
dernier à mourir avant ça c'est cool
quoi d'autre que nos petits enfants
mais du coup la réincarnation en quoi tu
crois pas du tout pas beau marais au
coeur de sion je suis pas toi tu meurs
est-ce que tu revis après on n'en sait
rien comme comme dans le bouddhisme
oui enfin oui pourquoi pas quoi on n'est
pas du tout en train de parler de la
partie non mais bon c'est un sujet
intéressant
bon c'est reparti sa partie et c'est de
nouveau un problème de
deux serveurs et du coup si jamais on
ira sur sur un autre serveur choix que
ce serveur italien du comme c'est sarah
français qui marchait pas dernièrement
il y avait on avait des bugs et si
jamais on changera on ira vers le
serveur français donc d'en faire partie
donc il ya toujours un an et demi heure
et demie et on a une position hyper
compliqué là tu vois ses deux pions en
c5 et c6 que j'ai mis un rouge gorge là
bas ils sont dangereux parce que ils
peuvent à tout moment
tu as ils sont à deux coups de dames
sérieux tu dois un peu les surveiller
comme du lait sur le feu
moi même le protège mais encore en plus
barrés tu ailles cic mis en fait tout le
monde derrière colonnes de selah sue est
dur de sang ait eu à y regarder il veut
essayer de passer comme ça pour pour
prendre le pion pour libérer nuit en
fête et pouvoir en les envoyer ensemble
en fait écoute c'est hyper dangereux
pour pour sergei la sergei à mon avis il
est pas très bien parce que tu vois le
sont le point fort de sergei c'est le
pion g3 regarde et le point il est un
peu tout seul son point exact bas 27
problème a résumé en fait le truc c'est
que c'est son point fort mais il est
seul donc il peut pas s'appuyer sur son
point fort en revanche duda il assez de
ces deux coureurs cyclistes quoi et
enfin les avances qu'enfin ils sont là
il valait 1 à moins qu'ils réussissent
attentats piège à faire un truc ou quoi
ce qui est possible c'est une position
encore compliqué à beaucoup de pièces
sur l'échiquier écart yakine est réputé
pour être le meilleur du joueur en
défense du haut niveau il ya quand même
sa petite réputation on l'appelle le
ministre de la défense c'est son surnom
est dans le top ultra le nom aux îles à
evry bas il a été barré où il a été
numéro 2 comme je le disais
je dire actuellement il était toujours
dans le top 3 on y vient d'en sortir et
14 là mais il a été dans le top 8 encore
il ya quelques semaines au top top 10 en
tout cas mes liens de faire un très beau
mais tournant à la aux états unis tous
debout et de bord ouais mais là il ya
une mauvaise perdre je crois que je
crois qu'il a eue alors je sais plus
s'il a pris du poids ou s'il a perdu du
poids je crois qu'il a perdu du poids il
a dit que ce n'est pas trop réussi
alors est ce que quelqu'un peut
expliquer à 5 alors l'idée de à 5 c'est
qu'il veut donner une pions et encaissé
le pion c5
parce que ça enlèverait le défenseur du
pion du pion c5 qui est le cavalier mais
en gros c'est surtout un coup de fouet
parce que il n'a pas grand chose à faire
en fait avec les noirs et donc c'est un
genre de coude attentes
tu vas y perdre des matches du pouvoir à
cause de se plonger 3 par exemple vu
qu'on parlait du pion g3 tu vas y
contrôler les cases de sortie du roi
ouais mais ils peuvent facilement
prendre celle version web mais ça lui
coûterait sur les wii voilà elle met sa
dame la pin up c'est fini
mais pendant que tu prends ça tu perds
ça exact du coup oui si tu perds
celui-là y avait peut-être lui qui
partait tu vois après pour du cou une
affiche alors la bouffe et recolle
ouais il en reste plus qu'un sur deux
bon écoute les blancs sont mieux mais
c'est peut-être pas si simple que ça a
gagné quand même parce que le pion il
est seule maintenant et ça veut dire que
les noirs vont pouvoir l'attaquer tu es
bon point fr tour des huit se mettre en
phase avec l pions blancs parce que dit
protecteur ponant le chat il y à mon
avis c'est cuit mais faut encore que
duda soit précis c'est ça un truc c'est
que ça demande de la précision
bon
il a mis le quart ayant des trois est
hyper le purin carte écoute il a quoi il
a deux pions - avec les noirs mais
regardent ils attaquent sac un vendeur
défendu la réforme bâle a en fait ils
attaquent lui et si tu récupères
l'option des six ça va aller pour les
noirs en fait après le témoin le parti
là bas c'est le meilleur défenseur du
monde donc pas réputé pour être en tout
cas donc forcément il va il va toujours
bien défendre en fait il ne va jamais
laissé deux parties ou deux points à ses
adversaires donc validé cette l'idée
c'est de protéger le pion vêtements ces
primitifs et tu vois comme on parlait du
match du couloir peut-être un jour il ya
prise prise et la tour qui revient en c1
pour le moment c'est pas possible il ya
le fou qui protège mes joueurs tu vois
ce math du couloir dont je te parlais
tout à l'heure de se plonger 3
finalement ça commence à avoir une
petite utilité il veut peut-être faire
genre cavaliers bd au prochain coup et
s'il met sa tour en c2 ouais c'est aussi
l'idée c'est aussi une idée mais qui met
après son cavalier en d2 à la rigueur
non c'est sûr il va avoir du vrai il va
avoir du mal à tout organisée après
c'est un peu un très bon c'est le fou
prend le cavalier le comprendre qui
vaille est protégé par la tour on se
sent bien à rien tu aurais eu du mal à
finir le truc en fait après tu aurais du
mal à créer un math en fait tu aurais eu
le pion qui serait allé en f2 et puis tu
aurais pas pu attaquer le roi qui aurait
été en f1 ok alors là il met le cavalier
b2 et qui est protégé par le nom non
protégés par la nombreuse mais je pense
qu'il est très mal parce que tu vois le
pion il a survécu est un pion comme ça
en septième rangée à une casse de dames
c'est dangereux il va réussir à mettre
la tour est ok va mettre la tour en main
quand même où la tour en bessette
il va échanger des tours il va gagner
avec son pion à ça c'est un truc d'heure
j'ai remarqué dont tu es parti que tu as
du mal à faire c'est de garder un pion
ce qu'on appelle un pion passé éloignés
tu vois en finale ce pion là il va être
super fort parce qu'il est hyper loin du
jeu c'est toi il reste il va rester plus
de deux pièces pour les noirs ouais
c'est impossible de le savoir tous
savons qu'ils arrivent quoi et ouais
c'est surtout celui-là il est loin et ça
va être très difficile de l'arrêter
après ce n'est pas dicté arias qui n'y
arrive pas parce que comme je dis là
plus de vies qu'un chat et peu il peut
surprendre mais normalement ce pion là
il gagne sans aucun problème puisqu'il
est il va occuper toute la défense noire
ils vont être obligés de revenir vers la
bas et pendant qu'ils vont venir là bas
pour le défendre en fait lui va venir
faire la larrazet des pions de ce côté
là quoi donc cariat qui il essaye de
jouer roi et si son idée c'est de jouer
g5 pour s'en prendre aux pions et pour
tuer le cavalier mais regardez l'envoi
le pion à 6 là se finit pourra jamais le
récupérer avec un fou bafoue ses cinq
cavaliers des sept échecs fourchette
vrai sauf une de ses filles donc tout ça
va prendre l'aventage à la surprise
générale dans victoria donc il n'a pas
si bien défendu que ça non ben ouais
après peut-être c'est tout ça qui a bien
atteint ils avaient l'avantagé peut-être
s'il a bien attaqué quoi mairie gagné
donc duda qui prend le qui prend le qui
prend le dessus
gaudin qui lead way i koné j'aurais dû
parier tu vois je suis pas versé après
on semble qu'avec les bookmakers plus
dur je sais pas si on est en corse et
les bookmakers mais aurait peut-être
bientôt
donc ça c'est une ouverture je te
recommande pas trop de fer absolue de
faire b3 foulée de la sceptique ou c'est
pas mauvais mais c'est un peu dur à
jouer parce que tu vois tu laisses le
centre à l'adversaire donc je te
recommande pas trop de jouer ce genre
d'ouverture au début c'est pas ça
ressemble un peu à la ruse en eau
le débat est un peu tu as déjà testé la
méthode ruiz battue me l'a fait contre
moi mais je veux dire quoi tu l'as déjà
un peu joué non j'aime tant mais je te
dis moi que je fais que une seule
ouverture c e 5 e 4 comme je jeu mais en
fait je reconnais pas d'autres et j'ai
pas envie de me lancer dans les trucs
que je connais pas parce que je veux
faire n'importe quoi ou alors je fais
des 690 je suis plus comme en 1960 960
la la rigueur bon pour moi je fais
d'autres ouvertures quoi étape à
regarder la série de vidéos qu'on a fait
avec fable sur l'écossaise non non non
il faut que tu ferais faut que tu
regardes c'est pas mal pour pourra
prendre une petite ouverture et
comprendre des idées c'est pas mal tu as
une heure de vidéo à regarder
c'est un peu long mais mais ça va donner
des idées pour jouer avec eux quatre et
jouer peut-être de manière un peu plus
agressive que ce que tu fais aujourd'hui
non je suis obligé de faire de la pub
pour ma chaîne turiaf
allez vous abonner à la chaîne des puys
stream
d'ailleurs tu as gagné vachement
beaucoup d'abonnés ces derniers temps là
en août il me semble tu gagnes le genre
250 par jour grèce et une envolée
s'apprête effet la vidéo avec avec moi
aussi je reviendrai que bah en fait
quand j'ai fait mais quand j'ai sorti
mes vidéos avec y penser nos vidéos
d'avant qu'on avait fait tous les deux
ont également commencé à monter ont vu
mon avis c'est des gens qui ont vu que
josé chacon voulu voir les parties que
j'avais fait précédemment
mais s'ils ont vu cette vidéo et du coup
qui ont fait ça a super bien référencé
ma vidéo 2 contre carl scène et j'ai vu
ça en fait elle tombe dans les
suggestions vidéo en fait du coup de
partout maintenant et elle est monté en
l'espace de
deux mois de 56000 vue à 140 milles donc
elle a vraiment well as pris 80 milles
vu en l'espace de deux mois alors que
c'était une ancienne vidéo mais c'est à
la suite de ta vidéo et qui pensait en
fait ça fait ça a changé un truc dans
l'algorithme youtube en fait à vidéo de
avec qu'ils pensaient sûr les échecs
enfin pour moi en tout cas je pense que
ceux qui ont regardé les vidéos avec qui
pensaient ils t'ont eu en
recommandations tout simplement
ouais et du coup comme eux ils sont
restés ils ont dû faire tu sais de la
fidélisation d'audience sur mes vidéos
du coup on fait ça tous les gens qui
regardent un peu y penser au toit ils
ont dû commencer à avoir mes vidéos en
suggestion en général même sans regarder
le truc d'échec je pense en tout cas ça
a changé un truc dans l'algorithme de ta
vie deux équipes ans est clairement et
bah du coup on va construire face une
partie un de ces quatre bah écoutes je
viendrai chez toi puis on se ferait en
live mais ce sera quand même mieux de se
défaire au soleil à la plage qu'en
normandie non aller ce week-end juin
chez toi tu pourrais en plus en même
temps tu m'as prendra le russe
j'ai toujours voulu apprendre le russe
c'est plusieurs que jc chèque
j'ai fait des cours de russe pendant un
nombre et à obtenir un petit niveau
bah en fait c'est parce que j'avais un
séminaire en russie pendant deux
semaines du coup pour un non on a appris
le russe
on avait même appris par coeur à la
musique à l'hymne je sais plus quoi
kalinka
un truc c'était trop drôle parce qu'on
l'avait chanté du coup dans un bar us et
avaient tous les russes qu'ils avaient
chanté avec nous à lire et 13h c'était
trop cool
pourtant je sais qu'ils ne s'étaient pas
très friand des français à cette époque
à américaine s'est elle à l'époque tu
sais où on disait que c'était des
connards parce que avec l'ukraine tout
ça voilà du coup il n'avait pas trop les
français à ce moment là mais ils ont
quand même chanter avec nous ils nous
ont pris dans les bras et tout c'était
cool bon usage des armes un peu bourré
en même temps le truc c'est qu'il
peuvent ne pas t'aimer en fait parfois
mais le problème c'est que comment ne
pas aimer quelqu'un une fois que tu as
déjà vu de votre cas tu vois ça devient
beaucoup plus difficile pour un russe de
pathé mais en fait ils deviennent très
gentil ça doit être kalinka ouais c'est
sûr à mon avis ça doit être cette
chanson là bon du coup cette position
absol37 portant tu vois là tu as une
colonne ouverte ça pour tes parties
aussi ultra important ce que je veux
dire là et c'est hyper important de la
contrôler cette colonne quand il y en a
qu'une encore plus important parce que
du coup ça permet de faire voter tour
alors que l'autre il peut pas faire
jouer ses tours donc ça c'est j'ai pas
si tu as un concept que tu as déjà vu le
concept de la colonne ouverte non post
post - non non c'est pas un concept que
tu que tu maîtrises moi je maîtrise rien
que vilain va falloir pura vida
ouais c'est un concept stratégique
important du coup c'est concept de la
colonne ouverte à une colonne ouverte tu
mettais tour dessus et tu prend le
contrôle c'est pour ça que tu as dans
fait là les tours blanches elles peuvent
pas tuer ne peut pas s'exprimer
toi tu peux pas légitimement des mois on
va toujours dit que les tours blanches
avec soit toujours connectées entre
elles c'est juste c'est vrai c'est le
cas et du coup elles doivent être
connectés ensuite pour contre attaquer
des colonnes en fait revenir sur des
colonnes ouverte la reine devant le roi
parce que sinon tu peux de fourche enfin
un vrai coup à jouer et c'est pour ça du
coup que la cariat qui n'en fait ce
qu'il a fait c'est qu'il a laissé la
colonne b du coup le noir ont mis les
tours dessus et il en a profité pour
pousser les pions devant le roi noir
pour forcer les noirs tu à venir
mater et à venir défendre le roi et là
mon avis va tout envoyer vraiment comme
une brute 1 il va envoyer tous les pions
et avoir après je pense que les blancs
sont mieux là je peux enfin à spa que je
pense c'est que je suis quasiment sûr
que les blancs sont mieux il va essayer
d'organiser une attaque de maths sur le
roi noir bien il fait une paille ramène
toutes ces pièces vers le roi ça c'est
un truc aussi qu'il faut que tu portais
parti tu t'inspires pas de vous donner
toutes les pièces comme ça de faire une
genre de d'échappée de pousser la série
mais sa reine ans on sait 6 par exemple
ce serait bien pour aller pousser le
pion dans ça peut être pas mal mais pour
le prendre un peu à revers et l'attaqué
comme ça après le danger c'est que les
noirs de leur côté ce qui veut faire ce
qu il veut s'organiser pour bouffer lui
ai envoyé le pion et avec les noirs il
va envoyer du contre eux je mets le truc
c'est que j'ai l'impression quand il va
mettre ses deux tours là il pourra pas
faire maths parce que la case hd elle
sera protégée par le fou donc il pourra
cacher son van asch à protéger le fou le
pion avec le h2 avec le fou est attaquée
avec ses pièces après peut faire un
clouage jolie là il peut faire un moment
vous allez dire une bêtise
il aimerait bien rentrer là tu vas avec
lada brucy éventuellement parce qu'il
est souhaité moi je vois mais enfin
c'est compliqué et alors au pire il
sacrifie sa reine pour faire bouger le
cavalier et il en fait une autre à côté
d'un mec dur à cuire a réalisé là en
fait il veut juste gagner ça en force
allait prendre sa le pion aux six iep
rennes prennent ramener sa tour en
recettes après une fois qu'il aura le
champ libre et tu vois et chasser le
cavalier bêtement en fait je pense qu'il
va gagner avec les blancs parce que le
pion des six il est vraiment trop fort
je vois pas comment on peut défendre et
tu vois le temps aussi la pendule
regarde car yakine il a beaucoup plus de
temps que duda il est vraiment bien
autant peut-être peut faire flouer 4 x 6
et essayer de mettre la tour en fuite
pour mater vous faut 5 tours 8 matois
match du couloir regarde et là un coup
de match je pense que c'est imparable
je pense que tu peux pas éviter ça parce
que si tu ramènes la tour en b vitupère
le cavaliere chaque émeute voir
égalisation se serait finalement ouais
après car yakine joue beaucoup plus vite
donc généralement c'est bon c'est le
joueur qui joue vite c'est bon signe
pour lui c'est une ouverture espagnol je
passe tu connais il faut enlever cinq
toiles généralement là tu mets le fou en
c4 tu fais l'italienne et quand tu mets
le fou jusqu'en b5 c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'espagnol et l'idée de
l'espagnol sait que tu attaques
lecavalier 6 comme ça tu t'en prends
directement aux pions de 5
ouais on me l'a fait souvent celle là
est en général je mets le pion en d6 du
coup alors le
meilleure poussée de jouer à 6 l'idée
c'est que s'il prend c'est exactement ce
qui se passe dans la partie tu reprends
du pion d et sites mange le pion aux 5
tu fais dam des quatre récupérer moi je
mettais toujours en dessous comme ça je
me dis me le prend mais est toujours
protégé dessus alors tu peux le
provoquer en fait commencé par asus qui
permet de chasser le fou et voilà ça va
permettre à près de développer ton fou
de développer le fou là et tu as tu vas
avoir un bon jeu de développement quoi
et si tu te prends le pion le répète un
tas de petits dam des quatre qui va pas
c'est pas très conseillé de sortir
sodome au début non ouais mais là le
truc c'est qu'il va devoir bouger le
cavalier et tu vas pouvoir reprendre sur
échec et du coup bon ça va quoi les
dames vont s'échanger au pied bon du
coup retour vers la partie dont il a
fait roc dames f6 pourquoi pas des
quatre prises ou g5 d'amener 6 kelly
prend quelques 7 qui essaient trois fous
17 et b3 ok donc là tu as les noirs
leurs petits problèmes entre guillemets
c'est qu'ils ont des pions doublé ça se
passe très bien mais l'avantagé c'est
qu'ils ont la paire de fou et la paire
de fou généralement ça donne un petit
avantage donc d'un côté et un
désavantage parce que tu as les pions
doublé et d'un autre côté un avantage
que tu as la paire de fou mais là tu
vois il a pris sa reine en d1 moi c'est
un truc que je fais jamais parce qu'en
fait du coup j'ai l'impression de lui
donner un tour en plus parce que du coup
ça lui permet en même temps de bouger sa
tour qui est bien placé ouais alors
c'est dans la plus je me sens très bien
expliqués mais la plupart du temps ce
que tu dis est vrai c est fait
normalement tu veux pas venir échanger
parce que tu vas tu vas donner un cours
gratuit à l'adversaire exactement mais
là peut-être qu'il avait peur que la
dame s'en aille et que de toute façon la
tour vienne sur la colonne des lui
reprenne un temps sur saddam s'il y
avait un peu du mal à trouver des cajas
tu vois elle avait du mal à se replier
j'imagine que c'est pour ça qu'il est
venu en changer pour éviter de se faire
enfermer
bon c'est un petit peu avancé mais les
fous ils vont parler un jour un les fous
sa part à l'absolu un moment donné les
fous finissent toujours par parler et
peut-être en sortira en bekkat il va
venir un peu faire chier le monde avec
lui mettra peut-être l'otan aux 6 et
puis après il enverra les pions c'est
bobby fischer qui jouait bien dur de
position ce genre de final c'est pas
bobby fischer qui a donné un fou gratos
au championnat du monde
ouais je ne sais pas ce qui est vrai le
fameux coup il était désemparé après
allait prendre l'option hd via dans les
yeux dans le film le comment ça
s'appelle de ce film the sacrifice
ouais ça doit être ça où il filme
justement ce moment là avec précision
pita spassky alors tu ne te sens pas
bien tout ça j'adore ce moment mais du
coup c'est assez inexplicable quand même
comme ah oui c'est le prodige voilà oui
oui crois qu'il ya des mouches dans les
mains c'est pas qu'ils croient ces cas
une mouche qu'il dérange dans le dans la
lumière et un truc de fou elle était un
peu space un afficheur après montait un
peu
un peu fou quoi c'est que ça va arriver
d'arrivée de jouer des tournois puis
repartir trois rondes après faire un
forfait ou de revenir des trucs donne à
rémy qui m'ont dit que j'avais fait
genre 10 20 ans après un autre match
avec ce pas ce qui est juste pour enfin
comme ça en souvenir oui et c'est ça qui
l'a évalué les problèmes avec les états
unis d'ailleurs
ouais parce qu'ils avaient cessé avec sa
cause ce match là je crois qu'il y avait
deux mémoires prédit peut-être une
bêtise il ya des gens qui vont être plus
au courant que moi mais de mémoire il y
avait un embargo américain sur l'ex
yougoslavie et du coup le fait qu'ils
soient allés jouer le match c'était
interdit et c'est ça qui a fait que
après ils pouvaient plus rentrer aux
états unis
il y avait un embargo ray c'est ça et du
coup il ya plein d'histoires de fou
quand même avec avec les et chacun oui
il y avait aussi l'autre mec là qui
était interdit de jouer contre les
russes parce que sa femme était
soi-disant prise en otage en russie il
pouvait enfin les russes annulé à chaque
fois qu'ils participent et en
championnat
comment il s'appelait ce gala en russe
aussi hyper fort je ne sais pas mais
dans le chat qui vont te dire s'ils vont
trouver dans le désert on te dire quand
ils vont dire le nom tu vas dire ah mais
oui alors je n'arriverais comme cela
exact c'était ça mais tu as à me
revenait pas et c'est que ce mec-là
quand même les couilles quoi parce que
il avait sa femme plus ou moins en otage
en russie participe à l âme au
championnat tout ça tout le monde était
contre lille à il était remarquable
comme joueur il est mort il ya pas
longtemps d'ailleurs
karzaï et il a envoyé devenu suisse
après il est devenu suisse et il a même
joué pour l'équipe de suisse
la belle joue pour l'équipe de suisse
mais c'est un joueur extraordinaire
aussi un personnage ouais il me semble
qu'il avait battu tous les plus grands
joueurs russes justement c'est pour ça
qu'ils n'étaient pas très contents
il aurait pu devenir champion du monde
d'ailleurs bah c'était à l'époque de
kasparov et karpov nom de cartes pas
frais surtout de cartes paf
d'ailleurs karpov il était venu à rouen
il ya je sais plus quand même à une
époque où je m'intéressais pas forcément
aux échecs plus que ça mais ça aurait
été de maintenant je serais venu le voir
s'arrêter coup il vient il vient il ya
assez souvent
en france en fait karpov mais il faisait
des partis je sais contre une
quarantaine de joueurs à la suite
ouais des parties en simultanées oui
mais bien il vient assez régulièrement
faire des faire des trucs en france
c'est pas rare sépara de le voir tu peux
tu te situes tu renseigne un peu à
l'avant sous je te dirai si tu veux car
peuvent c'est un mec que tu peux
vraiment pas tu peux vraiment elle est
un endroit où il se retrouve terrain il
ya un truc qui peut être intéressant je
pense pas que ça marche mais ça peut
être de faire [ __ ] en c4 avec l'idée
sur pions prendre fait retirer les prend
et de par l'asa pas marché qui sait si
ce qui est prend des quatre accessits
fourchette d'ailleurs mais tu vas avec
l'idée de jouer avec un amas de pions
comme ça et d'envoyer tt3 captions un
contre un et a essayé de faire une dame
face aux pièces ça peut être intéressant
de faire ça parfois mais là ça marchait
pas et qui sait si ce direct sacrifier
une grosse pièce quand même faut être
sûr de soi quoi
ouais ça marchera pas souvent mais mais
ça peut être qu'il avait fait les
intelligences artificielles qu'ils font
ça surtout valff à 0
les partis qui est fait c'est assez
impressionnant mais bon si non mais ça
arrive de voir ça c'est un gros amas de
pions comme ça qui avance ces trucs
c'est dangereux parce que là le problème
des noirs c'est que bon non mais ça va
aller il va réussir organisé il va faire
ses cinq réceptions sont quand même
avancé mais faut qu'il fasse gaffe si
l'autre réussi à faire 3e de f4 et
commence à envoyer ça peut barbe et
j'aime bien les noirs en fait il ya une
grosse activité et il va peut-être
essayer de faire pions prend puis on
prend cavaliers à 5 et les autres va
réussir à défendre par cavalia un
j'imagine c'est un peu moche mais ça
fait le boulot ça défend quoi donc et à
cinq du coût direct et lamont ailleurs
cavalia hacker prend b4 à joly l'idée
sur fion prend c'est de faire [ __ ] en
v6 un genre de fourchette aussi avec un
fou double attaque pas malgré tout ce
vrai c'est un petit coup de défense
sympa bon après les noirs peuvent
prendre en b3 reprendre prendre ici mais
ça a permis aux blancs de régler leur
problème avec ce petit truc assez les
grands faut le dire c'est joli
info lucie st pierre
donc cette affaire qui a aidé 5 pour
revenir vers b6 pour attaquer des six
mois mais ils valent prend avec son show
au nom j'imagine ouais mais bon là faut
il va pas le ce poste ça maintenant il
va aller où il va le prendre c'est sûr
c'est sûr mais le truc c'est que ma faim
avec les blancs faut pas un moment donné
le père de superman y faire attention à
la il peut prendre le pion la whey il
peut prendre ce à l'échec en plus il va
faire froid c3 il peut prendre ce pion
en fait je peux faire ça ouais il prend
et qui prend le vin ça ça ça ça et ça
mais cette finale est née elle va être
nulle théorique suis probablement 9,6 à
[ __ ] couleurs opposées quant à des
fous de couleurs opposées généralement
tu peux bloquer le pion plus facilement
bis qui a personne qui peut déloger sur
cases noires ouais mais il ya un pion
qui est un peu plus d'espacé que les
autres il est vraiment dans son coin ça
peut être un avantage quand même
pas ici apparemment ça fait 1
ok donc du coup il a fait tout prend ses
quatre avec plus ou moins les mêmes
idées de revenir avec lui cavalli sur
échec prendre ça et prendre sa flotte a
fait qu'avaliser si ce qui est pensé si
on prend 3,17 à ses trois cahiers ici
alors il ya toujours égalité matérielle
mais
mais quoi mais gaffe ou contre cavaliers
bon ça doit probablement être tenu
mais y'a ce pion c'est qu'est-ce qui va
rentrer en fout un cavalier en fin de
partie
on m'a dit que c'était fou parce que ça
prenait plus de enfin c'était c'était
plus dégagé donc il n'y avait plus de
possibilités
ouais et en plus le fou il peut il peut
il peut plus facilement dominé le cavani
clinverse mais bon il ya le pion passé
non les blancs sont un peu mieux mais le
truc c'est que si tu vois c'est du blitz
ya peu de temps et les cavaliers ça peut
faire des fourchettes
donc ça peut être dangereux mais je
pense c'est juste nul cette finale vois
tu as regardé le cavaly les hyper chiant
il menace qui prend ici
si le fou par là il va faire g5 le fou
par là il va faire cavalier échec
fourchette
il va gagner le pion donc tu as même à
ce niveau là avec les cavaliers et les
fourchettes ça arrive ça allait bien de
s'en prendre aux skis poste non mais le
truc c'est que le cavalier c'est à tous
les niveaux c'est difficile à gérer
enfin cavaliers mènent même tu vois au
niveau des joueurs du top 20 30 mondial
pam m même pour magnus en fait ça peut
être mangé un cavalier c'est toujours un
danger
bon maintenant il va essayer de
travailler il va le travailler au corps
pour essayer de se placer il va
peut-être c'est de remettre son roi de
ce côté là qui s'est tu allais il vient
de faire une petite barrière de corail
il reste deux secondes après il ya une
secondes par coup mais où il va il va
falloir la perdre je suis quasiment sûr
il peut y avoir une idée ch4 g4 je vais
essayer de te montrer bon là ça marche
plus mais c'est de sacrifier angers 4
pour envoyer le pion h
non mais là ça va ça va aller tout seul
regarde le pion et là c'est fini
regarde le roi arrive en d3
il va mettre le cavalier en dix-sept le
doit faire re 5 peut-être nom est
d'ailleurs prise prise roi prend 2,4 il
va partir encaissé sa voix l'a fait
chèque en premier au quai du mas kébé
trois échecs et c1 dames et tu vois ça
s'est joué sur une fourchette de se
demander pour chute non c'est toujours
les fourchettes 1,7 sur les fourchettes
qui décide avec les cavaliers c'est
redoutable alors ça a changé il avait d
4d 4 c'est un truc que tu tu fais quoi
quand on fait des quatre fois d'ailleurs
je fais des quatre aussi enfin du coût
de 5
tu te mets en face bas hockey à ce
qu'ils sont en train de jouer ça va
ressembler à un genre de truc qui
s'appelle une ressemble à un genre de
benoni avec tu vois les pions ou 4 et
dessins qui sont venus prendre le centre
est et d'un autre côté avec les noirs tu
vois des six touchés cette rock et à il
va jouer pour pour mettre la pression
comme ça sur sur la dame l'évolution
pour se compliquer du akkar yakine qui a
fini par prendre qui a fini par prendre
le dessus 1
nous réserve plein de surprises je pense
ça sent pas très bon honnêtement pour
duda parce qu'il accueille l'as pris dès
le le lead en début de match et on
aurait pu se dire que avec celui d'il
réussirez à essayer de construire
quelque chose
en tout cas le garder ou hockey a passé
ses distances et en tout cas mais le
truc c'est que le scénario des partis
car il joue beaucoup plus vite il prend
confiance
- il va y avoir de temps parce que tu te
rappelles que les la cadence s'accélère
là on joue en 5 minutes plus une seconde
à prendre adjoint 3 + 1 et après on va
jouer une minute plus une seconde là les
bullet à la fin c'est le truc je
comprends rien
exact et vu que car yakine il joue plus
vite
logiquement ça veut dire que plus les
parties vont s'accélérer plus car yakine
va prendre de l'avantagé en fait donc
c'est ok le scénario sans que pense sans
laisse à penser que que cariat qui ne va
va prendre le dessus mais on croire donc
fou et 2 il va faire rock au prochain un
ventilateur vient de s'arrêter ça fait
du bien aux oreilles de l'écran des fois
je mets le ventilateur des fois je
l'éteins donc moi j'ai fini de manger
peut-être que vous aurez plus aussi les
bruits de bouche comme ça mais je crois
que tu couper ton micro dents à chaque
fois que tu faisais des axes d'accès non
les gens n'en attendait pas et moi en
fait quand tu au moment où tu muté en
fait
j'entendais le mythe je sais pas si les
gens entendaient ou pas sinon j'aurais
fait de la smr bruits de bouche à
oreille sa mère ça c'est encore un truc
spécial je comprends pas trop le truc
moi j'adore d'aller semer en moi je sais
pas pourquoi tout le monde déteste les
semaines je comprends pas du tout le
délire mais bon je préfère mettre de la
musique de leurs al aqsa sion juste si
je veux écouter 1
alors moi je suis bon je sais pas moi
les voix me relaxe beaucoup plus ouais
écoute pourquoi pas après 1 et après
c'était parce que tu as l air et à smr
aussi ça vient peut-être de là bas après
il est plus réceptif certaines choses
d'autres forcés au cas par cas moi je
vois je suis plus réceptifs par exemple
au au bruit graves aux voix grave n'a
que voix aiguë ouais à une voiture et
non moi ça ne me pose pas du tout mais
une voix bien gratuit warhawk moi ça me
repose et écoute pas du goût de la
lecture
de tout de tout ça brûle unies m il n'y
a pas longtemps ses livres les livres
audio
ah ouais mais c'est pas ta déjà tu as
déjà essayé livres audio non je préfère
je lis beaucoup mais j'ai toujours lu
enfin j je préfère largement lire à un
frey livre parce qu'en fait de ces
souvent des livres c'est compliqué que
je lis et du coup je reviens toujours au
phrase précédente lors à chaque phrase
je reviens je tourne la page précédente
pour recevoir déjà ce qui avait été dit
avant c'est des trucs pour les livres
audio ça c'est pas possible tu vois
c'est pour ça que j'ai jamais pas encore
mieux livres audio pas ce que je fais un
peu la même chose que toi j'aime bien
revenir en fait vous lire une phrase
qu'est-ce qui vient d'être écrite ou
ouais voilà adjoint c'est pareil pour
les vidéos tu vois vulgarisation c'est
bien un moment mais je veux vraiment
approfondir un sujet il ya que les lives
en tout cas auquel tu peux enfin qui
pourront aider quoi mais dans tous les
domaines
les vidéos pareil pour les vidéos des
chèques c'est pour tous pareils
évidemment les vidéos le livre d'échec
c'est quand même spécial à moi j'en ai
acheté j'en ai quatre ou cinq
j'ai jamais réussi à les finir tout ça
c'est dur talla bréviaire de tarnac
horaires non attends si tu veux je peux
te le montrer
alors le dernier en date je vais te le
montrer
ghazi ouais c'est toujours intéressant
les livradais fait parce que c'est vrai
que souvent on en achète beaucoup tout à
tous les niveaux et puis on n'élit pas
tous vents le dernier en date c'est
celui-là edwards edwards lasker des
échecs
c'est vieux c'est des vieux bouquins
rééditer tout ça frotte ça ici comme la
course et on m'a dit que c'était le
meilleur pour débutants allait vraiment
bien alors tu reconnaîtras meba alors
faut avoir la foi quoi c'est à dire
parfois il parle d'un truc est en fait
les chicchi et à la page précédente
donc tu es là à regarder les pages comme
ça à savoir en fait faut avoir
déchets qu'ils en fassent quoi les
livres des chèques en général il faut
avoir un échiquier devant soirée mais le
problème c'est que moi quand je lis un
livre c'est toujours dans le train enfin
tu vois à des endroits où je peux pas
mettre un échiquier en face en fait
c'est plus difficile mais tu devrais
tester les leçons sur trois points comme
ça c'est bien elle sombra vachement bien
fait
ouais mais j'ai pas de connexion dans le
train t'as pas la 4g non mais la 4g dans
le train en a toute une histoire
ouais ça marche pas en normandie on
s'est également dit je passe dans un
tunnel toutes les deux minutes
c'est un peu bloquée puisque les leçons
du coup elles sont enfin surtout choses
comme elles sont pas mal fait et ça peut
ça peut être utile à temps je suis en
train juste de réfléchir un truc je me
demande si on peut faire caler g5 f6
d'un match 5 puis on prend tourcoing est
fluide
non ça va pas marcher je pense héros
apprend tour eiffe un échec et mat est
meilleur on prend la fuite et la dame va
pouvoir venir comme pour colmater angers
6 en cas de prise sur échec marche pas
ou marches auxquelles à fait guéri j'ai
5 ans et plus sur m6 qu'elle et son idée
ce que tu vois ça ce sens là que les
blancs ils ont beaucoup de pain regarde
les noirs ils ont des pièces qui sont
éloignés du jeu a les droits et les
blancs tuchan qui peuvent rapidement à
ce que je veux dire ramener dames et
tour sur le roi bas ils ont plus poussé
que les noirs en tout cas le blanc ils
sont plus avancés way et du cou du coup
là l'idée de défense et sa surprise
prise cavaliers prend qui semble très
menaçant il veut une nouvelle fois faire
coulisser la dame pour pour tous
protégés ce baume qui sauve tout quoi
ouais alors qu'elle éloigne visuellement
elle éloigne
mais en fait celle qui revient qui
revient défendre et on n'a pas le temps
de faire du des six parce que
systématiquement responded to b cet
essai le roi blanc qui sera affaiblie
donc ok ça sans aucun effet quel point
f7 sacrifice est fou g4 bien joué il
ramène le fond en défense et maintenant
qu'est ce qui se passe sur tourcoing fc
a dû rater un épisode 1 moquer mais
qu'est-ce qui va je comprends pas j'ai
raté un épisode est d'ailleurs un truc
simple c'est pas possible c'est une
pièce emprise gratuite ok pour la cara
qui il est malin je pense il est une
pièce de mansle à alexis mais on est mal
mais lui a donné y aura tous logo ouais
il a dû penser que les attaques
fonctionner ok il redonne la dame parce
qu'avec john holmes
ouais il y avait des échecs perpétuel ou
d où des merdes
mais il reste avec de fouet une tour
c'est plus fort qu'une dame
ah ouais bah regarde ces trois points
six points 11 points contre 9 au même
niveau mobilité dom com ouais mais tu
vas voir le foulée de fou et la tour il
va arriver un petit peu envoyez le pion
il va faire du fou échec
tu vas voir tu vas voir moi tu vois par
exemple quand j'ai deux tours et que le
mec en face à une dame
il me la mets toujours un ouais ça fait
peut-être des double attaque des trucs
comme ça reste un enfer quand bien même
j'ai dix points il en a neuf c'est un
enfer c'est plus difficile à jouer avec
quant à plus de pièces qu'elles sont
plus diffusés plus difficile de trouver
de l'harmonie mais tu vas voir que là ce
niveau là normalement hill valley va
réussir à faire parler le matériel le
seul petit souci c'est que les blancs
ils ont tué les deux pions s'il réussit
à les pousser ensemble ça va faire mal
non vous l'esprit m'en parler les foires
de spirou
il faut vont parler t'inquiète pas ils
finissent toujours par parler on va voir
il peut avoir un plomb gratos là s'il
veut mais en fait je pense et surtout
enfin les deux mêmes
il peut en avoir deux gratos après je
pense est surtout intéressé par essayer
tu vois de tabasser c1
du coup qui prennent le a5 offre le
bacon big 4 et puis ça pousse tout seul
ouais sans se faire contre attaquer le
roi au passage parce que le roi il peut
se retrouver faible mais il n'arrive pas
duda là il réussit pas à trouver il a
réussi par l'agencé ces pièces en fait
tu risques après ce si il fait donc le à
5 puis b4 après il peut toujours revenir
sur la colonne eux pour peu que le pion
arrive adam tu vois ouais mais si tu
commences à jouer passif l'otiv a
commencé à soutenir son pion il va
pousser s'arrêta ouais ça va être un
problème il faut pas qu'ils mettent leur
marche avant cette sanction
ainsi commencent à arriver vers 3 e 2
après ça va être menaçant quand il
laisse le pion emprise mais pour ouvrir
les lignes proche du roi avec assez fou
regarde comment ils sont forts il a pris
ça fait une pression en europe et en
plus clouage de la banale et ils
allaient prendre l'autre pions jouer
avec loges de quoi la tour
bon mais bon il va envoyer le pion à
adama non halal déboule un wii va faire
perpétuel non il envoie le pion tu vois
que tu ne donnes peut-être plus forte
mais plus de mobilité et de mobilité il
n'a pas réussi il n'a pas craqué par
contre la colonne h la maille mais
lequel est le plus dangereux est ce que
c'est le pion à la potence il fait 1 800
il prend là
la tour après il fait ça donne mais
c'est bon là il n'a même pas qu'il
manque un temps pour faire ça mais à
travers des bad as me vite c'est vrai
mais il a été roi g7 où quelque chose
mais regarde ce qu'il va faire et là il
va il va pousser et il va prendre le
pion et offre plus il prend le truc
ouais c'est bien joué ça s'est fini là
je pense c'est que le bouchet quoique
regarde le roi se fait contre attaquer
ou pas n'ont même pas le roi monte à la
charge
ok avec quelques secondes sur la pendule
tout peut arriver là il ya là il peut
faire des erreurs peuvent faire l'un à
l'autre peut faire une erreur mais bon
allez en plus faut qu'ils regardent
toutes les cases que les fous prend
prennent qui se mettre sur une de ces
cases la tap il envoie le deuxième tour
à je préfère vous le pion se protéger
tout puissant pour aller déloger salah
et on donne une à la tour comme ça il y
avait peut-être un il doit y avoir une
double attaque
il devait y avoir un très bon double
attaque quand une seconde à aigues
marines table leblond way
du coup cariat qui n'était vraiment pas
très bien un moment donné il a gagné et
à mon avis ça fait mal tu vois pas ce
que c'est une partie pour duda où il
aurait pu recoller au score ils auraient
pu revenir à égalité et là il se
retrouva il se retrouve à moins 2 il a
complètement craqué doute à cette
position c'est une police et une
déposition est plus théorique des échecs
là qu'on lancera regarde de regarder
c'est ce qu'on appelle la berlinoise et
ça a été analysée sur analysé / / /
réanalyser et il ya même des variantes
qui sont théoriques jusqu'au 35e 40e
coup qui mènerait nulle forcé et ça nous
arrivait dans un autre match de
speechless entre maxime et enak à murat
à monde et de voir une partie où ils ont
joué 35 ou directement quasiment sans
réfléchir et ils sont arrivés à la nulle
n'importe quoi mais comme ça tu as ils
ont ils ont joueurs je me pose ce genre
de choc
ouais bah c'est le truc c'est les
ouvertures les
c'est le truc le plus chiant n'aime pas
trop quand ça arrive parce que c'est à
quoi ça sert de jouer si c'est du parker
quoi plus genou après c'est laisser les
échecs c'est le haut niveau si tu le
sais les échecs moderne mais bon tu as
des joueurs c'est comme ça comme la
judoka qui font de la lutte quoi ils
font plus du judo face à celui qui
poussera le judoka autre au dessus d'eux
après après pas tu as des joueurs par
exemple comme carl scène tu vois carlson
c'est un joueur qui était connue
maintenant il veut un peu plus théorique
amant mais quand même ils essayent de
sortir le plus tôt possible des sentiers
battus en fait donc c'est pas tous les
joueurs qui jouent du jeu vous la
théorie à fond mais ça c'est une
variante qui est très théorique la
berlinoise
ça se peut que ce soit encore théorique
moi je la connais pas trop parce que je
la joue pas donc je suis pas spécialiste
mais tu vois là aussi s'ils jouent sur
un clouage est fou de 6,6 des clous et
si tu prends le fou en dix-sept il va
reprendre un f4 tendu
tendu compliqué
pas comment ça va ça va continuer cette
histoire salies mane qui dans le chat
que plus théorique que la berlinoise
tumeur ironique à mal des smileys avec
la tête
ils font fait des petits qu apparaît
partout les petits capable de partout
bayalan âge d'or aussi qui est très
théorique c'est vrai mais la major faut
au moins ça donne des théories ça ça
donne des parties amusante il ya
beaucoup de sacrifices et il se passe
beaucoup de choses
la berlinoise non seulement c'est
théoriquement plus c'est chiant parce
que c'est une finale et que c'est pas le
truc le plus excitant à regarder mais là
tu vois la structure de pions des noirs
elle est un peu pourri tu vas regarde
voilà il ya plein de petites îles au
partout quoi ouais il ya de l'eau de
partout et après ses solides parce que
la tour en achetant qu'elle est assez
mal placé thual a du mal à tuer là a du
mal à revenir comme dirait femmes à
rebrousse poil coiffe un fou c'est alors
viendront h4 pour essayer de gagner le
pion mais à lecavalier qui peut venir
angers 6 c'est pas évident c'est pas
évident mathieu en plus ce qui est un
peu moche c'est que tu as tout est sur
noir là bas tu connais ça le concept du
bon fou du mauvais vous redis moi un bon
fou c'est en fait mauvais fou c'est
quand on fout il tape sur ses propres
pions balle et on peut dire qu'il est
protégé sinon ouais mais on peut voir ça
comme ça mais d'un autre côté faillites
ap 6 tab sur du dur pas il tape sur du
dôme sur du bois peint casse et ces
boisés quoi là il veut faire tour g5
avec l'idée que surtout reprendre pour
affaire qui on prend il pourra ré
agencer ses pions et les remettre en un
îlot donc c'est assez bien joué qu il
veut vraiment fait tire vraiment profit
de cette tour de duda qui est mal placée
et puis cavaliers au bord à moi on m'a
toujours dit cavaliers marrant ouais
après voulait rebondir
il veut rebondir en fait ouais enfin
dell fulda lecavalier qui veulent
prendre sinon ouais mais du coup il y
verse à tour ah oui d'accord puyméras
option mais bon peut-être il fera à tour
g6 protège le pion ses protégés il fera
tour g8 après tout reprend g2a
d'ailleurs c'est la partie parce qu'on
vient de regarder c'est ce qui est en
train d'être joué
c'est justement ce qu'il vient de faire
et tu vois la tour elle va et le pion à
f4 il va être hyper utile parce que tu
ailles bloc le pion j'ai failli à la
prise en passant est peut-être qu'un
jour il peut faire c'est 6 3 o6 plus
tard un est complètement enfermé la tour
peut-être qui sait mettre le pian h5
enfin vous on en est loin mais ça peut
exister enfin je veux dire que ça
m'échappe je sais pas ce qu'il fait sur
tours j'ai dit ok peut-être s'il fait
froid et faim tout reprend j'ai deux
tours point m6 échec
ouais c'est ça quand tu as il contre
attaque ce pion l'art en fête c'est
hyper compliqué comme partie sinon il
met son faux en cinq noms comme ça des
protège les deux en même temps
ouais mais il se fait avoir par le
clouage way
ah oui et puis là oui d'accord comprend
de la tour plus tôt mais bon il s'en
fout parce qu'en fait les blancs est ok
les blancs qu est ce qu elle faire il
veut le faire pour eux deux ils veulent
protéger le pion
et après peut-être éventuellement le
ramèneront f est à prévoir du coup les
noirs il se laisse pas mourir tu arrives
à envoyer ses pions tu as un pion de
plus il veut pousser l'arrêt ce qui va
et surtour d1 il veut faire droit aux
6es tu ailles bloc ils bloquent la à la
case la case de retrait en d5 de la tour
de la toile est pas à l est pas super
quoi il ya un mois la sueur bouffe elle
est pourquoi il la met pas à votre nom
aïe
j'allais dire pourquoi il avait plongé 5
il va tout de suite attaqué le web ci
soit au keops il peut plus là en plus
belle il veut faire h5 chasser la tour
noire est menacé depuis rêve 6 c'est la
mère ne peut pas trop il va être obligé
le maître sont fous en deux sets je
pense non quitte à 17 pions qu'on met du
coup là la tourelle va pouvoir va
pouvoir repartir matos on était obligé
mais c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour
carrier keynes que c'est tour maintenant
elle va pouvoir revenir en jeu ça allait
plus enfermer quoi est ce pion il va
pouvoir avancer
il est mal car yakine mais il domine pas
vraiment ce match de la tête et des
épaules un et il souffre un peu je
trouve les affaires food et s'imagine 2e
étage
duda il a 20 ans et qu'il est urgent il
va s'approcher de la trentaine je pense
car yakine on peut nous dire dans le
chat aussi mais va s'approcher gentiment
de la trentaine doit avoir 28 je pense
en général les meilleures performances
quel âge pour un jour de choc je dire
aux alentours de la trentaine géré aux
alentours de la trentaine maintenant les
joueurs il n'est même plus je ne réponds
pas un esprit plus vives quand compte
avant tant m et à moins de connaissances
voilà mais ce que l'esprit plus vif et
plus que les connaissances grande
question
non il manque un peu de tu vois tu ton
ton esprit reste vive quand même un
jusqu'à 30 tu n'as pas de baisse
vraiment ça se tient je revois encore
carousel quand il fait son match contre
kasparov alors qu'il a 8 ans et qui sont
merde parce que kasparov film est à 10
minutes à jouer chaque coup et qui va
avoir les autres partis à côté il avait
fait ils avaient fait nul d'ailleurs
oui le fait nul puis il avait l'air de
se faire chier tu vois les ide pour
jahier je veux dire elle ne devait pas
avoir tant de connaissances que ça tu
vois c'est karl scène ouais mais bon tu
as eu l'esprit vive contre la
connaissance à l'e mail à l'esprit très
vif coiffe un fou les plans de vivacité
mais oui il est spécial mais oui quand
tu es quand tu es jeune balata un petit
jeune qu'on appelle prague ananda qui a
12 ans et qui n'a fait un match a pas
longtemps contre es les sauts à ses
souliers numéro peut-être 9 mondial en
ce moment y'a pas longtemps il était
numéro 2 et
et le petit il a peut-être perdu je
crois qu'il a perdu deux et demi à un
ennemi tu vois il a gagné une partie sur
quatre c'est un futur génie ouais c'est
pas on dit que c'est peut-être le futur
champion du monde rêve et il a un nom
comme nationaux et études indien on n'a
pas un indien dans le top-5 d'ailleurs
il me semble il ya eu à nantes qui a été
champion du monde
deere qui était champion du monde avant
carl sais c'est lui qui a faim c'est
qu'intel lui a pris le titre est là pour
le moment non il ya des indiens qui
monte mais on n'a pas dans le kop top
mais il ya pas mal il ya deux petits qui
viennent y en a un qui s'appelle donc
prague annan en bas et le deuxième gamin
qui arrive s'appelle niall stars ils
essaient aussi un indien en fait donc
dans les gamins qui viennent ya deux
indiens et ils seront peut-être enfin
l'un des deux sera peut être champion du
monde un jour ou en tout cas ils seront
dans le top 10 mondial c'est quasiment
sûr fin hockey / j'exagère un peu mais
c'est très probable soit ferait nul non
non non non là les blancs ils vont ils
vont envoyer des pions tu vas voir on va
aller prendre le pion c5 il a deux pions
de plus et il va pousser ses pions
tu vas voir ça il ya aussi un petit
ouzbeks qui est très fort qui s'appelle
abdou paso rohff ou abdou sato rohff et
qui est aussi très bon fais toi ya ya ya
quatre jeunes enfermés qu'ils sont bons
ce moment il ya deux indiens un ouzbek
et en allemand mais nous malheureusement
en france on n'a pas vraiment de relève
à maxime
on n'a aucun français jaune très bon
second
non malheureusement non malheureusement
on n'a pas de parent on a absolument oui
on a le petit absolument fin fou pour m
rigolez pas c'est la théorie
mais le niveau physique ça marche
toujours figé finning feeling voilà
comment ça va se finir mais oui en
france on n'a pas de
on n'a pas de relève malheureusement a
pas que nos jeunes soient pas bon c'est
pas ce que je veux dire
mais mais on n'a pas de
deux joueurs qui sont assez bon si tu
vois c'est incroyable ce qu'il est en
train de défendre là car yakine c'est
impressionnant le plomb ils vont pousser
jusque là c'est foutu oh là là c'est
foutu
mais le fait qu'il ait trouvé du contre
jeu et qu'il est blanc en danger c'est
incroyable il aurait dû perdre juste
sens en lutte si tu veux en limon lit le
petit maori this way il est bon le petit
mbao risi c'est vrai mais il est quand
même très loin de paille sera peut-être
grand maître un jour il sera peut être
dans le top 100 mondial possible mais il
est très loin des desprat ghana mandat
des joueurs qu'on a cité plus tôt il est
très loin d'être grand maître encore
même maître international en fait il est
très loin et il a déjà tête 11 ans alors
bas il est très fort et que fort que moi
à son âge par exemple on sait pas c'est
pas assez vos lames et par rapport aux
joueurs dont on a parlé c c'est juste
pas la même galaxie quoi d'ailleurs j'ai
le club de chèques de marseille qui m'a
contacté par mail pour pour que pour
savoir s'il voulait bien m'entraîner ou
je sais pas quoi
je vois si tu connais ouais il va le
temps traîner c'est cool intensité quoi
s'était pas entraîné ce qu'ils voulaient
d'ailleurs je crois que je vous l'aurais
pour moi il se faire du buzz quoi non
ils voulaient un partenariat avec moi
mais alors attends je sais plus en quoi
ça consistait il voulait me faire venir
à marseille
je te retrouve sa des bleus répondent
d'ailleurs nord est a longtemps où ses
récents
attends je te reçois alors non c'était
28 juillet ah oui alors c'est m inviter
à participer à un événement que nous
organisons en décembre à marseille le
festival international d'échecs
cette année sera la onzième édition qui
voulaient morgan a invité à ça l'idée
serait de vous avoir régulièrement au
club ou sur skype pour vous préparer aux
échecs et réfléchir ensemble à la mise
en place de cette action au sein de
notre événement et moi je leur ai dit
que ben ammar si ça allait être
compliqué vu que j'habite en normandie
mais c'est un beau tournoi c'est un bel
événement c'est un tourin qui est devenu
un tour magne annuel le touran marseille
il sera membre d'honneur du club et vous
sauriez joueurs licenciés au sein de
marseille échec du coup sert à rien en
cro bat quand habitants normandie voilà
c'est compliqué tu veux que je déménage
et que tu viennes 10 dans le sud pour un
de ces quatre prime avaient dit qu'ils
me paient les voilà c'est là nous
prendrions en charge son déplacement et
en hôtel
ça fait quand même beaucoup d'allers
retours pour apprendre les échecs
allez tu peux faire par skype pour
apprendre j'ai vu l enfant leur une
fille qui est assez bien classée la qui
gère ce club là apparemment oui tiens
c'est sympa que je connais
du coup cette partie regard là c'est un
peu plus excitant parce que tu as une
attaque sur le roi regarde ta des pions
qui sont montés failli l'envoyer des
pions et le roi blanc il sait pas à te
faire un peu grise mine quoi parité
grise mine n'est pas grise mine grise
mine mais auquel est peut-être pas à
fond quoi et du coup les noirs ce qui va
le faire tu as et ramener les tours ici
en face ouvrir la colonne et allait se
[ __ ] en b2 ramener la dame un jour et
à les mater en force
en gros si ça se passe bien je suis pas
passé ces six loups en hausse à face et
l'idée générale c'est l'idée générale si
tu veux après les blancs ils vont pas
dormir ils vont pas se laisser faire
mais enfin déjà tu vas faire ça à
doubler mettre sa tour en des 8es venir
un peu attaqué la colonne vesely des
soeurs pour ça que le joueur avec les
blancs tu as aimé la tour en bien failli
contre l'ouverture de la colonne quelque
part
donc
moi qui va ramener tour en b 8 je pense
et on va voir ce qui se passe mais moi
je suis plutôt pour pour duda là pour
qui légalise que ce serait sympa annonce
y avait quatre et demi quatre et demi à
moi je te dis que j'étais pour lui moi
je suis toujours pour celui qui est en
défaveur
ce que les anglais appellent la dordogne
underdogs wayne tha le chien valence ou
du chien quoi c'est lahoud cider c'est
le joueur qui est pas favoris je connais
outsider mais underdog je connais pas
assez par an donc en termes underdog
fait un chien qui les maintient en
dessous la bataille favori et puis tu as
we came souple ouais bon du coup je
voulais vous montrer un truc comme en
deux temps en fait oui acheter une
superbe bd sur les échecs
non je connais pas un manga de voir ça
du coup comment est-ce qu'on amène cette
attaque y va il a caché son roi ici il
va ramener la tour évoqué ce café cariat
kinski la milf ou en d2 dans l'idée sur
fion prendre pour faire faut prendre et
couvrir ces deux peut-être avoir envoyé
du b3 un jour mais le pion à nos gènes
pour amener les pièces fait on arrive
bien plus avoir le pion à effet retour à
5 et à les mater en force donc et je
vais raconter
ok il a fait plus on prend pour gagner
un pion mais il s'est pris ces trois
prises
courageux quand même c'est voir ça de
médée up
alors parce que je vous avais montré le
livre le dernier livre que j'avais lu
mais il ya aussi cette bd qui a très
très bien qui s'appelle le joueur
d'échecs le joueur d'échecs de stefan
zweig
ah oui l'ont fait ils ont fait une bd
hockey est en fait tu vois c'est ce qui
est bien avec cette bd c'est que tu vois
par exemple la tad et c'est pas des fins
et souvent avec beaucoup de cases en
fait c'est très tu recommandes je vous
recommande pour les amateurs d'échecs
je suis là tu es tu là fini déjà août et
hanté en lecture
non je ça fait longtemps que j'ai fini
le jeu là je lui la noël cette bd la
joie c'est cool parce que ça c'est
beaucoup de cases en fait c'est des
effets d'optique avec les échecs tout ça
j'avais lu la nouvelle en fait j'avais
beaucoup aimé la bd sorti l'année
dernière on a offert le but à la pendule
la bda tu as vendu on n'avait pas réussi
à régler avec le rajout de temps
d'ailleurs
mais je pense pas qu'on parle c'est
bizarre parce que pourtant c'est pour du
l'officiel tournoi où je ne sais quoi et
ensuite aller bien ta pendule mai
écoutez 91,7 pour du lent donc j'étais
un peu dégoûté quand j'ai vu qu'on
pouvait pas je sais pas si c'est nous
qui risquons pas à la règle et où aussi
donc si c'est pas possible
mais bon on avait l'impression d'aller
regarder sur internet et ou non après on
n'avait pas réussi à banon n'a pas
réussi à régler
du coup la regarde ce qui se passe un
truc marrant c'est que les blancs ils
ont ils ont sacrifié une qualité sne
appelle une qualité donc une tour contre
un fou mais du coup regard il a un deux
pions pour est en fait tu as quelque
part ses pions il dominait et dominer la
tour-blanche pas la tour noire pardon
donc les dents ils ont rendu la qualité
pour tuer la matte pions et le roi blanc
il reste toujours un peu en danger cieux
mais peut-être qu'il va essayer de faire
du dameuse cinq dames à 5 tours à 4 et
tu vas venir re prendre à revers quoi
possible et les blancs de leur côté
qu'ils protègent le pion c mais
peut-être que les noirs vont juste
prendre le pion de peut-être ils ont
poussé en trois pour ce faire un pion
passé c'est la soirée des pions pas à
ces écoutes à leur tête il va faire 3 et
après il pourra peut-être soutenir le
pion avec avec 4,4 passes paraît
dangereux quand même cette boîte qui va
perdre du co le pion sur la crème de
quoi bein oui le problème est bon car il
veut il veut pas il veut pas il veut pas
avoir ce pion ce pion survivre en
trois-quarts yakine avec les blancs il
peut prendre aussi à les faire damas six
échecs tour à 4 mais je suis pas sûr
qu'il puisse vraiment faire grand chose
ok donc il donne le pion pour détruire
la structure blanche et il fait dame f5
i'm naze tour à quatre matchs regarde
c'est joli ça c'est beau ça
je suis maintenant et ils menaceraient
serre que les blancs doit faire quelque
chose contre ça et il n'a pas dit me
faire la mesa rhénan ces deux ils
auraient pu faire dame ces deux mille à
avoir peur de quelque chose peut-être de
tama cinq tours à 4 quelque chose comme
ça bon ça aurait changé leur énoncé de l
est ou bien pour protéger non mais
peut-être qu'il voulait faire un échec
et venir prendre comme ça pour menacer
de rentrer par là après away exact et du
coup c'est pour ça qu'il est monté avec
leur en a deux pour monter à la volée
comme ça comme un échec
à la rigueur il poussait en b3 tu vois
le pion
ça dépend si pousser la direccte b3
temps j'essaie de te montrer 6 pouces et
la dire mince des fois c'est pas facile
quand ils jouent en même temps six
pouces et la direccte b3 et avait tout
reprendre et 3 et d'hommage aux sommes
sur la bonne voie
ok et s'y faisait ça je vais te montrer
tout de suite il faisait chaque remontée
tour à 2 ans fils à propos du coup c'est
pour ça qu'il est monté
inquiet mais son roi finalement il est
monté un peu cher quand même un fou
monte à la volée comme au tennis ou afin
tu as gagné l'us open en ce moment du
federer du machin est maintenant il va
va reculer de nouveau en c3 rêve mais
sur tf6 va sûrement faire tours 5
et il va venir échanger les tours avec
tours 8 échecs ci peut s'y prend et
après sans les tours il va gagner et
donc elle va faire être quatre il va
protéger la tour et tu peux pas prendre
le pion pour le moment en tout cas rien
faire dame e4 probablement ou tours 8
une entrevue qui peut passer que oui
mesdames eu 4 ou c5
il ya plusieurs options je ne sais pas
mais tu vois il assure à ses pions là
ils vont gagner tu vois ce que je veux
dire à moins qu'ils aient un problème
est qu'ils se prennent un tueur avec son
roi soit faible et qui se prennent des
échecs sinon ses pions là il gagne un
mâle adulte prom en fait ouais quand il
pouvait il a eu une opportunité pour le
prendre ce pont là il fallait il fallait
le prendre
il fallait le prendre mais bon il a
voulu jouer son attaque et il était pas
loin de mater un il ya peut-être dames 7
qui paraît un peu fort mais bon piont
prendre et puis on prend très fort aussi
ok là c'est fini prise en 8es dames 7 et
non pas me peut-être que darif 7 gagne
mais faut calculer mais sinon tu peux
aussi refaire d'apprendre cet échec pour
faire un échec ici sa voix il cherche le
plus précis wadhams était mal joué
qu'est-ce qui fait ok ça va gagner quand
même c'est très mal oui ce qu'il a fait
mais ça gagne enfin malgré non ça gagne
mais bon un peu étrange comme ça devait
être bien j'ai dû rater un épisode met
donc partie importante tu vois pas ce
que c'est la voie la norme ias pause
faille ils se sont trompés ils devaient
pas continuer voilà parti a été annulé
donc après la première heure et demie de
jeu donc à la mi-match absolue qui
arrive qu'ils mènent 5 et demi trois et
demi sans surprise en mai scénario pas
beaucoup de suspense en dans les échecs
ouais faf là quand même il ya deux
parties où il aurait pu enfin c'est
facile à dire après un mais à chaque
fois que j'ai commenté des partis avec
toi où il avait toujours un favorise
toujours lui qui gagne comme quoi tu
vois on n'est pas un jeu de chance
coiffe un fou le favoris l'emportent
toujours à la fin non mais un peu cruel
pour duda parce que je trouve
personnellement qu'il a très bien joué
duda tiens il est pas loin en fait il ya
vraiment deux parties qui étaient serrés
qu'il a perdu et c'est au final c'est là
c'est ça qui fait la différence
bon après si l'un 20 ans et que
quelqu'un à qui ni lendemain 28 là
encore lui temps devant lui pour
attendre son niveau oui oui oui non mais
c'est un des joueurs de toutes façons
les plus doués de sa génération et à mon
avis va aller assez loin ce plus
s'appelle yann christophe bass un prénom
plus ou moins français donc bon genre de
jean-christophe meute est allé en
pologne moi je me dis pour le chat
allez voir l'avancement de la bd pour
ceux qui qui savent de quoi je parle du
coup cette bd à la rivale arrive quand
on sait maintenant on a les dates way
avant on disait des trucs meilleur
n'arrivait jamais à les tenir cette
promesse
elle a en fait tu sais même quand ça va
être envoyée mais là j'en vois une
fourchette de semaine on sait pas
jour précis mais ce sera début octobre
mieux octobre grand maximum oh [ __ ] et
s'il ya des gens dans le chat qui iront
à kerry la bd ou pas est ce qu'ils
peuvent nous écrire est ce qu'on a des
soins des gens qui vont recevoir un
léger vu qu'ils avaient eu un changement
de titre avant ta bd oui c'est dû aux
problèmes aux récents problèmes on veut
bien là ok j'ai compris
en fait j'avais page et quand j'ai vu le
changement de nom le suivre et c'est
dommage j'aimais bien le truc et ouais
bah disons compromettre plus la série en
avant maintenant que les personnes de
personnages 5 et des petits
développements pas forcément très
agréable je sais pas s'il ya des abonnés
à moi dans le chatt d'ailleurs possible
tout cas il ya des gens qu'on est con
bien là parce que je vois pas du tout et
je crois 460 c'est pas moi c'est pas
pour un soir de match de foot
il soutient le france allemagne et qui
démarre donc ouais c'est plutôt bien 463
tu vois et ouais ça m'arrive d'avoir des
gens je sais pas si toi et écrivent sous
tes commentaires il ya des gens qui
méritent parfois vrai j'ai découvert
absolvent grâce à votre vidéo sur
absorbe fond c'est très rare s'est
plutôt l'un vertes moi j'entends souvent
j'ai découvert des vidéos par les vidéos
de dab sols mais ils arrivent ils
arrivent j'ai des gens qui m'écrivent ah
ouais c'est cool de ce type sol sur le
discorde une vidéo my way
moi j'ai des commentaires de thé abonnés
mais un autre notre histoire on va dire
messieurs c'est sur les trucs des
chèques non qu'ils écrivent ils sont un
peu énervés et tout le temps disons que
ils vont pas très doucement quoi
incendie en commentaire mais tu sais que
sur les parties qu'on a fait ensemble
c'était trop rôle parce qu'il ya plein
de commentaires c'est ouais absolvent
interne nulle je peux plus tu es content
de gagner contre lui alors qu'il
enlevait sa dame avant la csn aux
commentaires polir que je te
c'est la traduction polie que j'ai
découverte et et vidéos grâce à ce à
quoi
ouais bon après il ya aussi tous ceux
qui ont râlé parce que j'avais migrants
m dans le titre ça c'était sûr c'est sûr
il ya ceux qui râlaient du coup parce
que j'étais content de gagner parce
qu'alors que tu as dans leurs états
d'âme mais dans la vie c'est pas mal
comme il des commentaires positifs quand
même ouais mais à faradje et husson tu
reconnais les abbott des abonnés je
reconnais mais j'ai de mes abonnés sur
tes vidéos des fois je regarde tu m'as
des commentaires sympas mais peut-être
justice ils sont peut-être abonné aux
deux chaînes ou peut-être tulle et tu
vas tu lé jeu laissant pas les les
échecs sur youtube c'est quand même un
monde à part dans les commentaires
j'ai beau dire dans toutes mes vidéos
d'échec nous ne sommes pas des
professionnels vous n'allez rien
apprendre avec cette vidéo nous jour
juste pour le plaisir tout le temps des
commentaires qu'ils gueulent en disant
vous êtes nul j'ai perdu 25 minutes de
ma vie et j'ai envie de dire aux mecs
mais pourquoi tu as quand on va
continuer à regarder pendant 25 minutes
tu sais tu voyais très bien dès les
premiers coups que c'était nul quoi j'ai
fait moi j'aime bien en fait ça me fait
marrer pas surtout celle avec vous sans
faute hier c'étaient mes préférés et
peut-être que j'aime bien la chaîne de
brousse aussi que je suis j'ai dû tout
regarder en fait de la chaîne d'y penser
donc peut-être mais elle était vraiment
marrante cette partie va moi j'ai bien
aimé ouais d'ailleurs on doit s'en faire
une quatrième sur che ce point comme en
live sur ma chaîne secondaire un de ces
quatre on se dit qu'il faut faire c'est
un live pour ça ouais bah si on veut
faire un live à peut-être que vous en
fassiez de d'ailleurs matches aller
retour
pourquoi pas c'est ce critère de la
marque avec commentée par kevin analysé
après coup on a failli faire l'analyse
de vos parties avec fable et d'ailleurs
c'est un truc qu'on n'a pas très cools
on a pas on n'a pas lâché le projet mais
bon
il ya eu beaucoup de choses jusqu'à
maintenant on était très pris et pas mal
de tournois fab était pas trop là ils
allaient en il allait entraîner les
jeunes de l'équipe de france femme il ya
une semaine
je croyais qu'ils faisaient plus partie
de sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
chez les jeunes il est il était entraîné
les jeunes auraient séché les adultes
qui fut sélectionneur ok + je sais il
est parti entraîner les jeunes et voilà
on avait pour projet de d'analysé à vos
trois parties et on s'est dit en plus ça
ferait un petit titre put à cliquer
mais en fait c'est con parce que tu
aurais dû faire ça dès que les vidéos
sont sortis tu vois ouais ouais je vote
direct aurait été en recommandation de
se détériorer gagner dix fois plus
d'abonnés
aussi je posterai surfer sur la vague
complètement
ouais mais je suis pas très fin en fait
bizarrement je suis pas très bon départ
en est ton but c'est quand même de faire
connaître les échecs car maximum tu vois
c'est vrai quand bien même ton but c'est
pas de faire le plus de vues possible en
découvrant les échecs devant moi je
reconnais plein gg commandes il ya plein
de gens qui sont arrivés sur ma chaîne
secondaire qui se sont mis aux échecs
du coup en découvrant mes vidéos et qui
ont approfondi des échecs en découvrant
la chaîne en fait mais 4e processus
quelque part quelque part c'est bien
comme ça ben moi je trouve que c'est
cool tu sois comme ça comme ça les gens
qui veulent vraiment approfondir mes
bons vont peut-être ont peut-être on le
fera dans tous les cas d'analyser vos
parties on voulait faire un truc bien
fait on voulait vraiment que ce soit une
vidéo ce n'était pas dans l'esprit de
faire si on veut on s'est dit ça fait un
peu de buzz évidemment mais mais c'était
plus dans l'esprit de faire une vidéo
pour vous donner des conseils à vous de
en fait du coup fait oublier plus sur la
vidéo pour que vous la regardiez vous
que pour d'autres pour que pour les
autres en fait j'en ai envie de faire
dans cet esprit là tiens voilà bon bah
absolvent a fallu plutôt jouer comme ça
bruce là c'est plutôt comme ça et faire
bondir un petit peu sur vos commentaires
aussi parce que les finales ça laisse un
petit peu à désirer les fin de partie
n'importe quoi le problème c'est que et
puis bruce le dis aussi d'ailleurs c'est
que on a trop l'habitude
bruce et moi de jouer que sur 13 points
comme tu vois et a dû on a toujours la
vue du ciel avec les pièces qui sont
bien tu l'aidés identifie très bien
financées 28 mai sur un jeu de plateau
tu as une vue qui est comme ça c'est pas
du tout la même vision du poteau et tu
vois des trucs que tu tu vois pas
d'équipé surtout chez soi quand même
c'est en faisant le montage que je me
rends compte
pourquoi j'ai pas fait ça pourquoi j'ai
pas fait si parce que là j'ai une autre
vue tu vois quand je fais des chéquiers
virtuel même bruce a abandonné si tu lui
as dit mais lève toi mais tout en
hauteur et qui n'ont les jouer comme ça
regarde normalement il n'a pas voulu
quoi ils ne respectent pas la 2d quoi il
est comme fabien était il est vrai échec
c'est en 3d respecte je suis sûr eu dans
le monde
maintenant il y en a beaucoup plus qu'il
joua sur ordi quoi c'est sûr même mais
même les pros en fait il passe beaucoup
plus de temps sur ordi a analysé que que
sur échiquier c'est beaucoup plus rapide
avec larron les gens quelqu'un écrit
dans le chatt petit à petit que fait des
gens qui ont découvert tâche nkm via via
match n 7 a fait cent fois moins de
personnes en fait qui ont fait leur le
cheminement la chaîne secondaire alors
j'imagine plutôt non je crois qu'ils ont
découvert le truc complètement
tu vois il ya un mec qui décrit j'ai
découvert la boussole en étant passé par
mitri mes poissons fécond ça n'a rien à
voir mais affaiblissent riblon tout d'un
coup ici mon poisson fait qu'on ne sait
pas pourquoi
evian après avoir l'absolue tient les
boissons fait qu on est tout le temps en
temps dans ce non enfin je sais pas mais
je regarde plus trop youtube en ce
moment honnêtement je suis très déçu de
youtube personnellement je trouve que
les vidéos qui sont mises en avant c'est
devenu n'importe quoi mais bon c'est un
avis personnel après mais c'était mieux
avant quand il y avait beaucoup mieux
avant leurs phrases
je regardais c'est un billet 5les et
essien te diront que c'est faux mais bon
voilà enfin ils disent ce qu'ils veulent
c'est que c'est comme ça alors c'est une
vérité c'est une vérité mais c'était
souvenir qu'ils ont fait et qui fait que
tu ne pense qu'au bon c'est très
possible mais bon peu importe enfin en
tout cas je regardais une petite vidéo
de brousse je regarde été vidés autant
sortant sort de moins en moins aussi bon
mais visite tu sors les deux questions
et tout ça mais bon je dois dire que
j'en étais j'ai quand même sorti quatre
ou cinq vidéos il me semble bon c'est
que deux interviews mais c'est les
interviews j'en ai j'en ai regardé
d'ailleurs pour avoir du courage en
trois heures non mais j'ai bien aimé
celle de bruce et j'ai commencé à
regarder mais je vais la finir salle
avec fabien olicard qui est très bien
réussi j'ai regardé salle avec bruce en
entier j'ai tenté cela mais j'ai pas eu
le temps de la finir fait regarder 30
minutes
d'ailleurs très bien lutter on doit se
faire des partis de gauche ressemblent
en ce qui a trait mady n'a remarqué mais
ne joue pas contre lui va rentrer dans
ta tête des coups que tu veux jouer
contre cette personne voit à chaque fois
que je fais des interviews moi je
propose en même temps est ce que ça dit
faire des parties d'échecs après
l'interview donc par exemple ils m'ont
dit qu'ils pensaient ils étaient super
chaud bon quand bien même on a fait les
parties d'échecs super temps après ta il
y avait david loi prend donc de sciences
étonnante donc un mec qui a fait math
sup et où tu vas donc moi je me dis matt
logique les mecs qui doit aimer les
échecs et en fait non il m'a avoué qu'il
détestait les échecs et après tu avais
fabien olicard tu vois donc fabien
olicard mentalist qui adore les chiffres
tout retenir les nombreux petits tout ça
les casse tête et tout je me suis dit
par ali doit aimer les échecs aussi
et bah non il me dit non je suis pas ta
j'aime pas spécialement les échecs en
plus je suis complètement nul
par contre je par contre je joue au go
allez c'est compliqué les effet à quoi
bon compliqué c'est facile à apprendre
on va dire après à manier mais bon enfin
je suis pas
je suis autant un débutant le que tu
vois donc après par gc un petit truc
bizarre excuse moi de te couper mais il
ya les deux joueurs qui se sont
déconnectés
regardez ce qui est en train de se
passer parce que c'est un peu bizarre et
je vais aller j'allais me renseigner non
mais en fait les échecs en france c'est
pas très populaire j'en parlais avec
fabien tout à l'heure et c'est beaucoup
plus populaire en espagne en allemagne
en fait la france un pays où les échecs
sont pas très populaires bizarrement en
tout cas pas grand chose qui a été fait
pour les échecs depuis depuis plusieurs
décennies et c'est un peu dommage parce
que la france était un des pays phare tu
connais philidor ouais ouais c'est la
défensive alors oui c'est un des plus
grands joueurs d'échecs de l'époque et
le café de la régence à paris où tous
les plus grands joueurs d'échecs du
monde venait jouer à la fin d'une fin au
18ème 19ème siècle et puis la tradition
en fait c'est un peu perdu et les échecs
c'est pas très joué sur ça ça ça parait
vraiment une grosse popularité en france
alors que tu vas en espagne si tu vas tu
tapes et cheikh sarr et dresse en
espagnol les tatas plusieurs chaînes
avec cent mille abonnés tata d'état des
dizaines de millions voire des dizaines
de milliers de de vue sur sur chaque
main sur chaque vidéo sur les youtuber
connu en russie c'est très populaire
aussi en allemagne aussi en angleterre
sont en train de reprendre aux états
unis complètement et en france on a
vraiment être un temps de retard là
dessus on a eu trop fixe sur le foot
je sais pas mais c'est dommage en même
temps que russie c'était le sport
national
je suis tu entends tu as tu encore
maintenant d'ailleurs ça elle redevient
en tout cas poutine illettrés chèques
seront connectés alors je suis en train
de demander
ils ont racheté tous les feux mais je
comprends pas en fait
alors est ce que c'est moi qui ai un
problème je suis en train de chantera
décrire écoute
mais non mais c'est dommage je sais que
la goana gars qui jouent aux échecs par
contre bah ouais mais je vais proposer
une partie d'échec parce qu'en fait on
m'a dit en commentaires sur mes vidéos
déchets khawaja gotaga y joue bien en
échec et où faudra que tu lui propose
alors je vais proposer en public sur
twitter retweeter il me semble une
centaine de fois donc il n'a pas pu
passer à côté tu vois je me suis pris un
gros vent et dans l'électronique qui se
sont mis aux échecs un mec qui s'est mis
aux échecs c'est le rire jaune aussi ah
ouais du coup tu peux peut-être le
proposer et plus youtube du coulis ouais
bah la santé de mme avait déjà refusé
l'interview donc voie sûre qu'elle
accepte une partie d'échecs oui enfin
beaucoup plus intéressant la partie
d'échecs comme un fou ça se dire c'est
très très bien quoi j'ai envie de jouer
qu'au nord mais je crois qu'ils
regardent beaucoup de vidéos en tout cas
on m'a dit j'ai des mecs sur le discours
de ceux qui sont abonnés à son à son
fils sur snap et on est qui écrivait
souvent que face au vent de temps en
temps qui regardait des vidéos des
chèques ou qui jouent aux échecs
allez-vous que veux tu c'est le jeu des
rois quoi fin tu es là tu attendras quoi
mais nous formons en tout cas une cette
année je me suis dit j'apprends le go on
et me reste encore trois mois armée le
fossé enfin cpc non mais c'est alors
commencé là bas ils ont recommencé ils
vont refaire une berlinoise la fameuse
finale de tout à l'heure mais à gauche
c'est plus vendeur plus compliquée
encore là du coup ils seront un peu plus
rock et la désavantage non ouais mais
c'est en finale c'est moins grave mais
oui pendant un moment on a moins grave
en finale parce qu'il ya plus les dames
et du coup sans les dames je fais
toujours aux gabelous justement qu'ils
ne fassent pas un coup pareil le prêt
c'est toujours plus compliqué pour
relier des tours
non mais tu as raison d'y faire
attention est à raison de pas vouloir
être des rockets tu as tout à fait
raison mais on va dire que à leur niveau
c'est une ouverture enfin c'est cette
fameuse berlinoise est hyper théorique
et ils savent exactement ce qu'ils font
ils savent exactement ce qu'ils font
donc il va se débrouiller tu vois il
fait il fait ce qu'on appelle un roc
artificiel il va venir il va venir
avec son rang bessette et ça aura une
valeur maroc quelque part mais ne le
fait pas dompter parti ça c'est pas
raison de faim voilà jeu juste pâte
apprendre un truc faux et tf1 je veux
pas d'après un truc comme ça ou en
finale tuapati retrouver ça ça va te
mettre en danger qua non est bonne façon
j'essaie de ne pas que ça m'arrive mais
peut-être faire flouer simple un moment
donné pour aller viser là bas bon du
coup il protège il va dévaster serait
avancé de mettre le cavaliere en c6
peut-être ou des cinq mètres laurent
bessette le four e7 la tour en des 8 tu
arrives à sivas agences et les pièces la
main dans le job qui dit poutine aux
échecs
soit ils viennent y soit eu peur c'est
un peu ça 2 pol droit de gueugnon mecar
yaqing du coup il en russie les failles
il est très connu et il est dit fais
souvent des rencontres souvent il fait
de temps en temps des rencontres avec
poutine genre tu vois à kariat clean il
va rencontrer poutine dans son bureau il
discute un peu d'échecs tu vois comment
ça se passe et échecs en russie et tout
est du coup il est il assez proche de
poutine cariat kim passe comme si macron
de temps en temps tu le voyais avec
maxime discuter un peu bon comment ça se
passe les échecs en france il ya une ou
deux fois par an quand je vois la grange
aux échecs khl ouais non tu vois pas
comment je vois aucun de nos présidents
jouent aux échecs en fait c'est ça la
fout quand même je sais pas si on a le
triste je pense qu'ils ont acquis qui
doit jouer quand même enfin pas les
présidents mais dans les politiques en a
forcément qui doivent le droit que valls
y joue aux échecs face pas que je crois
c'est que je sais et strauss kahn aussi
jouer aux échecs
par contre il ya un député de en marche
denis masseglia un truc comme ça qui
joue à world of warcraft
enfin qui joue à world of warcraft qui
était dans une top guilde mondiale
sérieux mais je te jure c'est cool ça
comme quoi et toi t'as guide ça avance
un peu à nous on est nul ou nous c'est
juste on s'amuse et puis basta on joue
pas pour être la meilleure
j'ai pas le terme d' être le meilleur à
quoi que ce soit et ta fille retourne
enfin kraft s'est tellement chronophage
ce1
ce truc tu avais vu la vidéo mythique
avec l'iran et jenkins au polygone
junkie ça ça à 12 ans cette vidéo là oui
oui auxerre mais les fantastiques cette
vidéo voilà ça fait 12 ans que je la
connais celle là ils en ont fait un
personnage et une carte des heures stone
tellement c'est connu ce truc là ouais
c'est hyper connue il ya même des
références dans les séries télé et tout
cas c'est un truc mais bon la vidéo
parce que j'avais adoré c'était
l'épisode 2 de south park sur sur
warcraft
je n'ai pas vu les jeunes hommes cela
est fantastique du coup cette partie
qu'est ce qui se passe là il se passe
que tu vois les noirs il est venu lutter
pour la colonne ouverte ce dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure et les blancs s'y
prennent le fou il veut reprendre et tu
vois ce fou il colmate bien les deux
pions là bas tu vas tu as les deux pions
passé et faire les deux pions la
majorité de pions le deux contre un il
est bien bloqué par le fou auquel ses
parents g8 avec la tour finalement mois
qu'il veut faire acheter
tu vois il veut s'en prendre option est
attaqué le roi peut-être même après mais
j'ai finalement le roi noir il se voit
il s'est retrouvé à l'abri ouais il est
bien là il est protégé de partout là
j'ai un petit soucis chronomètre on va
faire un aller retour d'angers le
chronomètre qui par partie je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai du chronomètre qui est par
partie ok c'est bon je le crois matière
party rock et c'est reparti ouais le roi
mais bon le problème des noirs tu as
c'est qu'ils ont du mal à pousser leur
majorité
tu as les trois pions là contre trois
les captures contre 3 ils ont du mal à
avancer parce que tu as les pions doublé
tu vois c'est difficile de ces deux-là
de les faire fructifier quoi pas évident
du coup les noirs ils sont partis pour
faire le con tre jeu et s'en prendre au
roi blanc et tu vois les blancs ils
essayent devrait être se protéger tu as
eu ton pions cavaliers ils sont sûrs ils
sont bien quoi d'âge leurs droits ils
essayent de de tenir le pen joue aux
échecs mais jamais avec les noirs face
alors le chat a fait son show et son
seuil son show aurait apparemment dsk
est un joueur d'échecs qui le connu
ouais non dsk est connu pour jouer aux
échecs
oui dsk joue je crois que j'ai eu pas
mal d'erreurs mais dans les politiques
français et c'est dsk et valls les deux
kivu bon alors est ce qu'on sacrifie
quelque chose et ce qu'on en voit la
qualité et on se bat avant avec
lecavalier après moi je serais tenté de
faire ça si c'était ma partie mais bon
je suis toujours sont tentantes et
sacrifier des trucs qu'on m'a tuer les
blancs ils veulent s'en prendre aux
pions aussi c'est les noirs ils montent
à l'abordage avec le roi pour aller
gratter tous les pions
oui bon ça c'est pas con ça utiliser ton
rang final du coup les blancs il en
voile plongée ce dont parlait tout à
l'heure
et puis après il lui il va mettre ça
tours angers 7 lui va mettre son
cavalier ans à chaque ballon parce que
le tour va prendre après enfin en tout
cas il va essayer de monter peut-être
son roi protéger en premier de mettre le
cap à saint gall et tuent leurs visées
après il va pousser c'est une saint jour
de course en fait et c'est celui qui
arrive en premier qui gagnera et les
noirs tu as enfin les noirs ils pourront
toujours sacrifié un truc con que le
pion et envoyer leurs pions de l'autre
côté
ouais ok ça va jouer à ça va se jouer à
rien ce truc là ça va jouer au couperet
mais les blancs pour ont réussi de
retaper le pion aux 6 après pour envoyer
leur leur deuxième éclaireur c'est hyper
compliqué
ce serait bien que duda gagne pour un
peu reconnaît
s'il revient à un point rien n'est fait
là il met sa tour du cou en fuite non à
élever le roi monté il va venir chasser
la tour sans faim ne va arriver à l'âge
le ca va faire table oui mais ça à faire
balle de l'autre côté aussi à elle va
prendre la tour du coup je pense que je
regarde il en est deux à temps faux faux
à oui voilà il faut qu'il mette son ans
il le prend après il se fait non mais
sinon il me rend à 7 comme ça mais du
coup il ya lui qui part à [ __ ] ah ben
il est foutu quoi car il peut plus
colmatée c'est moi ou alors ils essayent
de défendre mais c'est fini bien joué de
la part de duda il revient il recolle à
un point donc tu vois c'est chaud hein
ce match tonnes qui veut il peut c'est
une partie importante je pense y réussit
à tenir au moins là nul avec les noirs
il aura de nouveau les blancs après que
les blanches quand même un avantage est
ok ça peut ça peut recoller quoi c'est
pas c'est pas si clair comme match c'est
pas si clair en tout cas c'est plus
serré que ce que que ce que j'attendais
personnellement tous en a déjà vu dans
une partie précédente c'est théorique
imagine toujours la même ouverture on
fait quoi parle souvent d'un deux
joueurs qui se qui se rencontrent au
bout d'un moment ça se stabilise et ça
joue toujours les mêmes ouverture dès
que les deux joueurs sont plus ou moins
contents avec la position qu'ils ont
obtenu ils pensent qu'ils avaient donc
les noirs quasiment égaliser les blancs
pensent que hockey et n'auront pas tout
à fait égaliser et qu'ils auraient un
petit avantage à mendes à stabiliser les
deux joueurs considèrent que
[Musique]
que ça va quoi que cette ouverture est
convenable et donc ils se mettent ils se
mettent à jouer enfin voilà ça stabilise
une ouverture quoi c'est comme ça que ça
se passe
on a tué les deux joueurs ont volé grand
roque mutuelle et blanc ils ont quand
même énormément de pièces qu'ils qui
vise la halle dame et qui vise les
droits par bon c'est parce qu'ils
peuvent ramener peut-être leur tour pour
attaquer le pion tu as ce pion là il
peut se retrouver un peu bloquée parce
qu'elle purge cinq qui l'empêchent de 18
ans qui l'empêchent d'avancer quoi
ok ça prend ça prend ça prend peut-être
qu'elle est là tout ranger 4 maintenant
j'ai 3 je dois dire que c'est un peu un
petit peu mystérieux pour moi
eh bien voyez là tout ranger à surtour
g4 mf5 pardon j'ai compris et une
fourchette regarde d'avenir les
fourchettes
ouais je veux même s'il met à son tour
en f1 le cap non ça s'y baladent hamadi
ayari le plus on n'était pas déplacé ce
plan était déjà déplacé engine 3 qui l'a
déplacé du coup depuis on en a c'est lui
qu'on a déplacé en train de bouger même
peine surtout en arrière mais bon peu
importe peu importe leurs portes plus
fait depuis un officiel et peut toujours
pas jouer là tout ranger 4 blancs les
noirs ils sont bien agencé un finalement
regardent ils ont leurs pions g7 qui est
protégé par la tour qui protège les
pions ils ont le roi qui est bien qui
est bien couvert et à hong kong d'horus
il est pas mal et tu va regarder un
moment donné la ceca pion qui pourront
avancer face aux 3 donc je comprends les
noirs sont pas sont pas moins bien ici
après les blancs un petit peu d'activité
mais mais ça à sa siens quoi ça se tient
en tournée pour les noirs on est
d'accord on y pour doubt a pour le
moment d'entrer dans tous les cas fin de
matinée jusqu'au bout moi c'est soit 6
mai son son faux enjeu si ce n'est
qu'après avec la donne il prend le pion
à eux 6 1 bat rota dos pas je pars il
protège la sphère près du cou ouais mais
il ya le cavalier qui couvrent ouais
mais justement le cavalier couvrait pas
vrai oui à l'époque le cahier couvrait
paris gr il est venu couvrir avec le
cavalier justement et il est venu
couvrir
du coup à et ses positions pas facile à
jouer tu allais me lenouar ou une
meilleure structure de pions mais les
blancs ont plus d'espacé à ce pion
réussi s'il n'est pas très bien placé
parce que il est où il est bloqué il
peut pas avancer et il est fixé parce
qu'il se fait attaquer donc
c'est un problème et du coup les blancs
tu vois ils prennent un maximum d'espacé
les noirs ils ont du mal à à 4 avec les
noirs avec les blancs mais j'aurais
peut-être fait sekkat aussi d'ailleurs
parce que tu contrôles la case des 4
mais bon il doit se dire que pour le
moment ses cadres des noirs c'est pas un
souci donc il a le temps et peut-être
ils se réservent la casse pour le
cavalier regarde ouais je sais ce qu'il
va faire et peut-être appris la même
allée par ici par un chemin un petit peu
un petit peu long mais ça lui permettra
d'avoir un cavalier qui est placée qui
gêne le roi le roi noir là je pense que
les blancs sont mieux ok donc il revient
s'agencer est menacée de rentrer sur la
colonne des pour obtenir du contre jeu
d'un me 4 la difficulté avec les noirs
c'est que tu as tu peux pas faire grand
chose en fait tu dois essayer de signer
son pion f5 la possible tu prends
reprend protégé par la tour ouais et ça
te ra permis de régler le problème du
pion alors peut-être sur gt5 est ce
qu'il va garder ça et jouer comme ça f5
ça m'a l'air d'être bien joué il a pas
fait mais peut-être qu'il avait peur
qu'il donnait la case de 5 aux cavaliers
en faisant un f5 peut-être qui donnait
cette case là et qu'ils voulaient pas
avoir le cavalier arrivant au 5 mai
c'était pas forcément une heure c'est un
coup plus que possible
ok donc qui profite du fait que la dame
soit parti pour bouger le cavalier la
dame revient et menace le plus réussi ce
métier à la différence du temps on va
parler je pense ici
ce qui agace une minute 25 à kariat kiné
il reste donc toujours qu'on ce concours
ce contre la montre
ouais et physiquement c'est usant d'être
mal autant donc peut-être qu'à force ça
va ça va aussi un peu se payer au
physique pour pour duda je crois en la
fougue de la jeunesse
mais voyez très fougueux c'est sûr mais
normalement en dessous de 25 ans tu as
perdu aucun neurones
espérons que ces neurones lui permettent
de lutter quoi est-ce qu'il va prendre à
5 y sacrifie deux cavaliers n'ont ils
auraient pu essayer de prendre à 5 qui
reprend dans ses 5 et 20 kg et il est
solide pierre yakine à mon avis qui va
essayer tournez tournez tournez tournez
et poussé doute à la photo à
en essayant de jouer des coups qui sont
un petit peu insipide mais en se disant
qu'avec peu de temps à la pendule cognac
une seconde de rajouts que jude a un peu
craqué ici mais ça ça rennes en d3 après
il la met en b 4e en bessin et pardon
après il met son fou son café bio wheel
est à bâle à l'épaule il est bien là bas
ils essayent de c'est ce qu'il essaye de
faire en fait foyer trêve à la mettre en
merde du coup c'est plus possible
ouais mais il va tourner oui là c'est
hyper dangereux peut-être qui a aidé ici
c'est vraiment naze dame ses huit dames
bessette maths et sur dame elle fut dame
sait si ça non mais c'était surtout
menacé de venir là et c'était une partie
importante je pense qu est ce que je te
dise au début de cette partie précédente
c'est que si duda voulait qu'elle
pouvait recoller quand même ou en tout
cas ne pas se laisser distancer là il ya
de nouveau un petit break fait part car
yakine voilà il sans craindre une ans
qui s'appelle lentilles mais rend mon
numéro
ouais c'était à la mer' en est là c'est
laisser anti quoi est il ya deux idées
avec l'énorme structure de pions enfin
plusieurs idées mais en gros le problème
c'est le fou s'est vite tu vois qui est
pas sorti et on va essayer de régler le
problème soit en jouant avec 5 qui soit
en jour avec b 6 et 5 ce qu'il est en
train de faire comment il joue vite là
ça va changer des pièges linky doit
faire dame c'est cette eau est protégé
le pion et faut toujours faire gaffe
parce que tu peux te retrouver avec
beaucoup de pièces qui regarde ton roi
car avec les noirs alors beaucoup de
billets sera braquée sur le roi mais
d'un autre côté tu peux faire des tu
peux jouer solide face à ce qu'ils
essayent d'ailleurs ouais pareil
après sur un jouet avec j'ai ici c'est
toujours un cri du coeur sinon ouais et
sur tf6 à vouloir faire des matches 4 ou
g5 et l'attaqué ouais mais du coup ils
ne sont curieusement alors je vais te
montrer je sens que c'est intéressant et
si tu fais agissent pour empêcher il
veut faire ça et trompe plonger les
surcharger ah ouais quand on obtient
plus de complètement découvert un truc
quoi ouais c'est pour ça que tu as dû
jouer ici simplement à contrecoeur et
maintenant la difficulté c'est que tu
vas toutes ces cases noires et de son
faible et c'est pas forcément évident de
défendre mais il veut faire tout re huit
fois fuite sous g7 et tenir colmater
tout ça et là cavalli g55 ou évidemment
à regarder parce que sa menace le pion
au delà il pourrait mettre son pion c5
et après avec le fou il attaque le
cavalier pour faire découvrir le roi tu
veux faire ces cinq là non non non je
veux dire city noircissent élus autour
des noirs il met son pion arrive en 5e
ça fait découvrir le fou qui attaquent
le cavalier qu'il est obligé de prendre
le pion se fait découvrir le roi tu as
ouais mais du coup sûr c'est ça qui va
faire cavalier g5
il va menacer matisse mais c'est ça qui
va probablement être joueur c'est le
coût de la partie qui avait 5 c'est
comme ça que ça continue c'est très
logique comme suit deux couples et
maintenant il va vouloir mettre le
france et 3 par presque direct ou pas
pour essayer de son parce que tu vois si
lecavalier disparaît là il ya
m'attendais en revanche un truc que je
voulais montrer pour le chat c'est sûr
cavaliers prend à vii pour vous et sur
la découverte les cavaliers prend donc
on gagne pas de matériel et sur
cavaliers prend 2,6 pourvus sur la
découverte comme ça y'a puis on prend et
latour protège le cavalier
mais c'est hyper dangereux pour les
noirs parce que tu vois le roi lui qu'il
est un peu faible quand même un tout
tout tout le monde le tacle à la haye
adam prend 1,5
peut-être est sûre pions prend fois je
sais tu mates je pense à 1.95 gagnent
juste avant ce que je rate un truc très
jolis seins ce qu'on appelle le mc de
blackburn
il l'a pas vu ça macharia qui n'ont il a
raté la l'équivalent de taille la vue
est et foi je sais tu mates ces jolis
seins c'est étonnant de se prendre la
tête
tu as vu des trucs qu 1 2820 pas vu je
suis là quoi abandon du coup bah j'ai vu
ça vite mais c'était joli comme
combinaison dame france 5 sata plus
j'espère voilà moi je trouve toujours sa
bo de maths et sereine ouais c'est matt
de blackburn est en fait si je les
trouve ici rapidement c'est que c'est
j'ai fait un court ya pas longtemps et
il y avait ce truc là en fait à force de
commenter des parties d'échecs
continuent elles montrent déjà presque
plus forte les joueurs fort quand même
pas mais oui je joue mieux qu'avant on
va dire ça comme ça tu as les gens mais
te demande à qui on qui peut me parler
tu vois quand je t'ai dit tu devrais
danser une série de toi qui quittent
romeo au tournoi et tu fais la série art
ou un objectif qui voit et on te suit
les péripéties enveloppe on le fait avec
un mec qui est dans le chat tu as un mec
dans le tchador arrive on est tous avec
toi je fais sur ça marcherait de fous tu
vois tu veux tu veux que je retourne
faire des tournois mais en fait tu veux
tu veux me voir en sueur en pls
continuer avec moi mais non mais tu sais
un peu comme les comme les ya certains
youtuber à muscu tu vois qu'ils font ce
genre de truc tu vois genre tous plus 20
kg tu vois tous les jours tu les vois
enveloppe s'entraîner et puis faire des
concours et tout ça ce serait cool tu
vois tu fais ça sous forme de blog tu
enchaînes des tournois on ne suit dans
les colis c'est tout on le filme en
train de réfléchir sur le truc ta
première médaille ta première coupe et
puis petit à petit il gravit les
échelons
oui alors tête je te retombe comme une
merde et je perds absolument tout quoi
franchement pour que là tu m'as dit que
tu avais fais tu avais battu deux fois
le 2e ou 3e mondial là et puis là
également on fait nul doute été plus ou
moins gagnant contre carleton donc je
sais que tu es plus officiellement
classé mais si tu te re classe ça me
tend une chronique où je commence à
avoir hâte en deux ans et plus un truc
dans le chat je sais pas un disque
daniel reyne jeu m'a taillé un costard
avant le match contre j b alors c'était
contre qui ils te sous-estiment pas fait
j'ai un peu je me classe de temps en
temps avec des youtuber échec gp12 j'ai
plein de classe en cours ' j'en ai
plusieurs qui se taille un costard
daniel rêve c'est le vice-président de
check point comme c'est celui à qui tu
parles de temps en temps et je sais pas
qu'est ce qu'il a raconté ce que s'il
faut que je te lâches des gens dit moi
les mecs sains parce que je suis chaud
en fait y'a pas longtemps enfin il ya
j'ai des petits contentieux avec
certains mecs
le directeur de sciences po comme non
avec lui non mais peut-être bien enfin
vous êtes je vais être obligé de
commencer un contentieux quoi qui s'est
il dit que je suis un flyer non mais
attends mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
je vais écrire je vais écrire à daniel
immédiatement sait jamais une feuille ne
peux pas dire ce à quoi je vais être
obligé de cacher il dit que je suis
rapide n'est pas fort non mais attends
il n'a pas pu dire sadc s'est pas retenu
qui dit ça c'est impossible que c'est
impossible que rennes j'ai dit ça de moi
sinon je vais être obligé de faire un
scandale c'est pas possible mais non
surtout faites y un mec dans les tours
il ya des tournois que je joue un mec
qui fait du cndd banking
il se fait descendre son classement elo
pour vous aider des joueurs moins forts
sur chaque point sera quoi parce qu'en
fait ces temps où tu peux gagner de
l'argent et du coup il se baisse son
classement sur une chaise comme et quand
un classement plus battu vont des
joueurs moins forts et du coup j'ai
lancé un semis clash avec ce mec il n'y
avait pas eu un clash aussi avec luc
pitavy au moment où mr vieille j'essaye
de ne pas trop en parler pour pâques et
road rage sur les bâches sombres
c'est incroyable parce que c'est là où
tu vois que c'est vachement humain de se
clasher parce que même dans le monde des
échecs ta du drame à quoi c'est
incroyable dans n'importe quel thème ta
du drame à la ce midi je mangeais avec
un historien il m'expliquait qu'il y
avait également du drama entre les
différents historiens qui n'étaient pas
d'accord sur certains trucs tu vois ça
incroyable cette cure monde se prendre
la tête à ça après l'aller truc 99% des
gens s'en foutent mais après la avec
l'âge je te parle c'est pendant des
tournois qui s'appelle blé comme on
appelle les arénas et en fait c'est plus
des clashs bonenfant serre qui a des
mecs
la plupart à part à paris paul travail
puisque je suis pas content de son sen
bat ging là parce que en gros enfin je
suis très mécontent de sa mais sinon
avec les autres mecs c'est plus de la
rivalité saine en fait c'est que tu
joues compte des mecs comme tu as
l'habitude de jouer souvent contre eux
et tous dans la même en fait c'est un
peu des potes tu as je me
je me lâche de temps en temps avec avec
les mecs s'appelle leccese brasser les
plus gros streamer des chèques au monde
et des fois je me chauffe un peu avec
amman ou quoi mais le truc c'est que
d'un côté on se lâche mais d'un autre
côté on essaye d'organiser des matchs
par équipe ensemble et tout donc c'est
plutôt comment dire
là c'est plutôt de la rivalité saine en
fait avec lé avec certains mac avec quoi
avec robert s
par exemple un autre mec dont on parlait
qui je me classe le temps d'antan quand
je le joue en fait on s'écrit et où on
se respecte beaucoup et du coup ça
dépend en fait c'est à détruite c'est un
peu comme deux boxeurs qui se chauffe
avant match nul en feutre à la main dans
le vestiaire comme c'est exactement ça
est pareil avec un autre mec dont on
parle avec stioui s'appelle un mec c'est
si oui griffin
en réalité c'est un mec après les arénas
c'est si je joue bien en quoi c'est un
des premiers à m'écrire après bank tchad
pour me dire bien joué ou moins linverse
tu vois vous faites à des vrais clash et
à défaut clash est addict a déclaré
c'est comme les boxeurs c'est pour
mettre un peu de piment quoi d'après
temps là débat ça ça fait monter
l'adrénaline on va dire du coup il ya
plus de billets qui se vendait ou je
sais pas si tu as suivi les vingt
matches de boxe là entre deux gros
youtuber américain et pendant trois mois
ils ont pas arrêté de se cacher pour
vendre des billets et tout pour faire
monter la hype alors qu ils sont potes
comme ça ça qui me fait mais c'est ça
mais mais c'est un peu ça ces plans
marketing mais nous en fait comme les
tournois turbo chaque semaine ya les
mêmes mecs et tout au bout d'un moment
mais en fait à même moi j'en ai même
besoin pour me motiver tu vois si non je
n'ai pas forcément la motive tu as le
fait que ça tiens ça me donne envie de
n'est pas toi ça ça fait un peu monter
la pression
c'est cool mais oui c'est normal mais
c'est cool ça fasse ça c'est plutôt
plutôt positif mais après quand les mecs
qu'enfin par le mec la caf et du 7 bat
ging honnêtement ça me fait vraiment
chier tu vois c'est parce que ce n'est
pas la gueule ça va il s'est pris un
avertissement il s'est pris un gros
avertissement mais bon pour moi tu dois
pas prendre un vertueux je suis énervé
qu'on a normalement tu devrais pas être
un avertissement tu devrait dégager
direct il ya un peu con parce que si
vous voulez vraiment participer à un
tournoi plus
ou moins débutants il avait qu'a créé un
nouveau compte au lieu de faire exprès
de perdre et ouais mais en fait
justement pour éviter la triche en fait
ils ont fait un truc qui s'appelle les
arénas king est en fait pour gagner de
l'argent
tu es obligé de stream et a long way
pour éviter la triche justement et donc
c'est un tournant il ya que des streamer
du coup tu peux pas jouer avec un autre
pseudo ou quoi parce que d'objets du
avec ton pseudo
j'ai pas compris pourquoi le blog de
nouveau mais bon il avait une pièce je
crois qu'il est tombé autant est ce que
je suis en mauvais termes avec john
bartholomew non pas du tout non mais on
disait que c'était comment il s'appelait
ses textes et rennes jean fait gagner un
truc mais non en fait il n'a rien dit
eric bartholomé n'en est pourquoi je me
chauffe avec martine du coup de poing et
tournoi ouais parce qu'en fait dans une
de ses vidéos pareil
il disait que j'étais bon connais pas
beaucoup de temps à la pendule et quand
on a ajouté du temps que je devenais
moins bon donc du coup du coup quand je
veux contrôler j'ai voulu montrer que ce
n'était pas une question de temps quoi
donc tu vois des fois on a des messieurs
c'est pas méchant tu vois ce que je veux
dire c'est plus des ses plus des petites
piques quoi mais non tu as bien résumé
quand tu as dit que ça ressemblait à la
boxe teinte à relativiser
mais c'est dans tous les jeux comme ça
tu sais je vais jouer au poker pendant
longtemps et c'est un peu pareil en fait
on est 100 113 sur le livre est vraiment
pas mal
c'est pas mal ça tout à coup qu'il se
terminer ce soir je crois que c'est la
mi temps là c'est pour ça
du coup nouvelle série retouches et amis
ce serait cool ça va écoute on va la
faire avec ap ssol habsheim et quoi
écouter si tu l'as fait je la fais aussi
tu te lances dans le rhode que j'avais
mis aussi banon mais si tu fais un rop
ou jamie moi je te fais un retour un
truc aussi aux échecs ça va en fait je
peux pas faire un run ça fait le maître
et l'élève crise lance un défi
mutuellement à la rote de tout bon allez
on se lance un défi c'est la solide qui
arrive le premier à son objectif si tu
travailles beaucoup capter plus favori
mais comme tu auras pas le temps je suis
favori normalement alors après moi quand
je me mets un objectif en tête
g j'ai mon honneur tu vois qu'il ya en
jeu et du coup je suis prêt à sacrifier
certaines choses tu vois ouais mais ça m
arrive quand tu vas tu a entraîné à fond
ça me force à plus beau c'est ça être
mauvais quoi au final ça va être mauvais
pour nous vraiment heureux pour masquer
la vie pour un truc débile quoi c'est
génial bon du coup il ya un plan marrant
ici avec les noirs voilà qui n'est pas
très bon mais des fois c'est de mettre
ta maman à 8 pour venir contre attaque
fin pour venir jouer sur cette diagonale
mais là je pense pas que ce soit bon
parce qu'il ya un petit un petit mur de
pions et bon c'est pas c'est pas le top
- la phase 6 mais c'est pas mal non mais
c'est bien on est alors montée du coude
ou doll est ce que vous tapez peut faire
une remonte à la fin il faut deux points
du coup non ouais il est toujours à deux
tours mais il peut revenir
il ya combien de partis encore il ya
trente minutes de 3 + 1 donc il ya
encore un gros cinq parties de trois
+145 partie de trois +15 avec celle là
on va dire qu'ils encourent et huit
parties 2 1 + 1 de bullet et de forts en
plus un dedans ouais les jeunes
généralement ils sont bons et en plus
car yakine il joue pas trop en bullet
mais le truc c'est quand même une fois
que j'ai vu jouer en bullet qui joue au
touchpad il était déjà fort donc s'ils
commencent à jouer à la souris et qui
s'est un peu entraîné je suis pas ta
bulle est
c'est dingue mais t'as un mec que les
gens vont reconnaître dans le chatt
daniel narrow dit ski qui est un mec qui
me martyrise qui est vraiment très très
très très très fort et les rênes je veux
le prendre l'année prochaine pour pour
le speech est donc on ne commentera
peut-être l'an prochain et ce mec là il
est deux mille neuf cent soixante ans du
let ou 3000 et il joue au touchpad sais
pas si tu imagines du délire non mais en
général c'est des mecs qui font les
coups avant que le joueur adverse ce
jour fait ça
oui mais enfin quand bien même tu es
quand même au touchpad le mec en face tu
vois c'est il fait pareil que toi et tu
arrive quand même être être 3000 quoi et
je suis en train de regarder leur
classement du let du die les 3000 0-1 en
bullet et cardiaques et les deux 1993
donc ils vont avoir sensiblement le même
niveau donc tout peut arriver en fait
dans ce match en bullet ça peut tourner
ainsi s'il ya que deux points d'écart
angula que ça va vite après un mois ça
me fait marrer les mecs qui qui font les
coups d'avancé avant que tu as joué
parce que parfois je tombe sur des mecs
qui font ça tu vois à mon niveau 1 donc
on parle de mille neuf cent mille deux
cents lots max tu vois et les mecs c'est
drôle parce que je pense que tu vois
c'est un petit côté je me la pète je te
fais un coup d'avancé avant que tu joues
le problème c'est qu'en général c'est
pas le coup qu'ils avaient prévu que je
joue
et de tout genre une pièce mais
tellement facilement à chaque fois c'est
un petit joueur mais à ton niveau faire
défaire des faire des prêts move c'est
suicidaire tu peux pas tu peux pas
vraiment anticiper nous on peut savoir
parfois qu'elle couve est joué bon alors
attends là le pion detroit il est
dangereux mais il en train de se faire
entourer
donc je pense qu'il va réussir à le sait
on appelle en appelle ses pions
déception passée des dangereux criminels
fous sont très très dangereux quoi bon
là les noirs sont très bien je pense
mais il protège pas le cul on l'a aussi
non ouais il a ils pouvaient pas
j'imagine mais bon il a ramené un donjon
est un deuxième criminel et il va il va
les soutenir peut-être avec saddam tête
avec des trucs qu'on va voir quoi on
nous demande on me demande ce qu'est le
bullet le but let's et les parties en
une minute
ok dame b 5 c'était une faute il a
laissé caïds et 4 avec tempo
vraiment je serai bien que du dallas
gagne ça va au 12e jeu
tu vois si réussi à soutenir le pion à
la pousse et ça va être bien mais c'est
pour ça qu'il fait tout retour à vide
pour aller peut-être faire du tour à
trois pour aller faire après du damas 4
tu vas aller soutenir ce pion à fond
alors la dame à quatre peut-être pas
parce que la dame est restée à tour ces
trois bien jouer il faut qu' il faut qu
ils vraiment qu'ils utilisent ce pion
bon
peut-être faire du damas quatre tu vas
faut vous prend au cadre noir regard sur
qui on prend dame prend tout reprend
tout reprend sa grille un pion pleine
classe émanant du coup il revient mais
comme il a gagné le point 4 qu'il a
échangé contre ce pion là mais il a
complètement ouvert le roi blanc et il
va essayer de se venger sur le pion
détroit maintenant est ce qu'il va faire
et il reste avec un point de plus bon
c'est pas si simple à gagner mais ça
doit être gagnant puisque le cavalier en
fait en fin de partie
le fou et plus plus fort que le cavalier
sauf dans un cas de figure c'est s'il ya
du jeu que sur une aile ce que
lecavalier l'effort dans le petit
périmètre
et là le truc c'est qu'il ya que le jeu
que sur une aile puisqu'il ya plus que
tu vois ça va être ça joue que là en
fait fait ces cases là quelques
parallèles existent plus tu vois il fait
bien de mettre à chaque fois toutes les
pièces sur les sur les causes qui sont
pas celles du faux exactement là il en
profite pour gagner un titan sur le fou
up apple dôme le fourbi n'a pas vu
j'avais pas vu son nom lors il n'a pas
pu il a craqué il a donné la tour en 1
oh qu'est ce que c'est que cette partie
assez le festival c'est la fatigue
lillebonne de pièces comme ça là ouais
c'est la fatigue ap sol ses 6
même les grands maîtres il faut lui
donne des pièces comme ça quoi ouais
mais là en plus était pas c'est pas
n'importe qui et que l'échec l'une
entretenant se protéger ses chances à
peu ça peut tomber autant là aïe aïe aïe
je pensais pas une bonne idée de
d'échanger les dames mais un échec deux
échecs le quai qui vient couvrir ses
shows tour contre cavaliers c'est nul
ainsi reste plus d'options qui a que
tour un cahier ce sera nul
compliqué là bas
sa mort nous apprendre le pion là non il
ya eu droit qui ré attaquer le cavalier
là ça va l'aca est gagné pour pour les
blancs il va faire un échec il va
pousser un pion à ilan il a complètement
bloqué gagnez de la part de duda est
partie à rebondissements il a donné la
tour en un coup d'arrêt avec une
incroyable la sous-estimer c'est bon ça
c'est réglé pour moi car il a craqué il
a craqué car yakine pas assez cool ça
relance le match
ça relance le match
ap sol et il a changé d'ouverture aussi
avec les noirs avec les blue suede à vue
des quarts et se passait ils sont passés
ils sont passés dans une française en
fait par un ordre de coin un peu bizarre
il ya plus qu'un point d'écart c'est
chaud tout peut arriver
ça c'est une ouverture que je joue avec
les blancs aussi d'ailleurs
qu'un tout petit avantage avec les
blancs parce que tu as tu atteins 3
compte de ce côté là et c'est plus
facile de pousser des pions allèles dame
que des pions à l'oeil droit
scapa leroy derrière tout bêtement et
donc ça offre un petit avantage aux
blancs ça ça permet de faire voilà tu en
vois tes pions quoi et donc tu es un peu
mieux c'est pas grand chose mais c'est
un petit plus
alors
sur réception sont quand même bien
avancé mais bon normalement avec les
noirs ça ça doit tenir mes belles 6000
son cavalier en bessin keep your hand 6
ce serait comme allemand à l'arrêt ce
qui va le prendre au passage ou pas tu
vois et ce que quand tu y as rei peu
long je pense qu'il le prendrait je
pense qu'il aurait pris mais là
maintenant il peut le faire
c'est ce qui va faire d'ailleurs donc
bien vu mais ce qu'il veut faire tu as
et qu il a mis son cavalier en c5 qui
parlent mal placé aussi mais c'est déjà
faire pousser 6 à un moment donné
ces choix mais je pense que les noirs
ils sont bien parce que de rome
il tend le 4 le qui avaient des noms
pour chasser l'autre cavalier e
ah non non mais c'est par là mais on
surveille les c'est ce que j'ai dit ce
que je pensais est parti pour le prendre
et il va mettre la tour en des huit
après j'aime bien les noirs parce que là
les pions ils vont pas avancer en fait
il a fait re 5 f 5 tu arrives à envoyer
ses propres pions il va prendre de
l'espace à fond et il est mieux il est
mieux avec les noirs et c'est étonnant
on va peut-être voir la premier jamais
vu de telles surprises en speech sg
commenté énormément de matches et j'ai
jamais vu de telles surprises
peut-être que c'est ce soir qu'on va
voir la première c'est possible
franchement c'est possible parce que
j'ai l'impression de karuïa qui il est
en train de craquer physiquement il a
pas pris son petit à feu enfin je le
sent moins tranchant en début de match
tu vois je te dis c'est la fougue de la
jeunesse type orient ça tu te rendre la
fougue de partout assez varié très
fougueux ray de trèfle ou deux arrêts
avec eric lafond bon malgré tout car
yakine va peut-être pas la perte finale
et sky agence bien les pièces il a
ramené le rond b 4 non mais il a bien
joué
le fou qui même s'il est mauvais fait
une petite focale sur le cavalier tu
vois je remontera mais c'est important
tu vois il est fait 2000
tu as well as trois cases du cavally le
bloc locle et 15 d'avancé
finalement l'appel si mal
donc s'il prend là ce qu'il veut faire
ça allait se venger sur le plan des 3
mai car yaqing c'est en train d'avancer
qui même là du coup là c'est difficile à
dire il a peut-être faire un petit coup
de tours h7 avant prendre le pion là je
sais pas il ya six aussi j'aime bien les
blancs mais bon je sais pas peut-être
que j'ai tort tonnes blanc le blanc
ouais j'ai l'impression que tu vois je
n'aime pas ce rouennais dans les cordes
tu vois permanente cavaliers il a perdu
son socle est ok va peut-être faire
cavalli vrai hockey avec les noirs ce
qu'il veut faire c'est qu'il veut il
veut échanger le foot le cavalier essaie
de faire nul face et y carnacki il a
perdu 15 kilos et c'est ça il a fait un
régime il a perdu 15 kilos il dit que
depuis joue moins bien c'est pas pour il
a perdu tout ce poids en fait il est en
surpoids qu'est ce qui va arriver en
fait comme quoi tu vois des fois des
petits détails comme ça qu'un stylo de
plus ou moins et tu way
ton cerveau marche moins bien parce que
normalement cariat qui a été champion du
monde double its en plus c'est un des
meilleurs joueurs du blitz au monde
il doit enfin tu as il doit pas être
dans un match aussi serré face à duda
normalement ça doit être ça c'est parce
qu'il a vu poutine lui encore mis la
pression
poutine qui fout vraiment souvent et
c'est étonnant
c'est étonnant cette tradition des
échecs hamel s'est un peu perdu en
russie
bon et 635 je viens sur des lives échec
tu te dis a pas grand monde mais en fait
l'année dernière quand on faisait les
lives ensemble on peinait à dépasser les
200 et la vidéo qu'ils pensaient c'est
cool hein c'est vrai ça montre que dieu
tu progresses bien au niveau communauté
quoi ouais ouais on commence avec un
pied en suisse on va les trucs avec
twist les premières pages les machins
donc ça joue aussi
après je sais pas si aujourd'hui on est
vraiment en première quand on en
première page première page en fait en
vidéo d'accueil on monte jusqu'à 1000
1200 donc on doit pas être environ en
page d'accueil là enfin on peut être en
passe de l'accueil mais on doit pas être
en vidéo principal donc les gens ils
scroll pas trop mais mais ouais y'a plus
en plus de monde où la lie à un petit
plan qui peut exister c'est de ramener
l'euro en baisse il faut faire attention
pour menaces et mat
là il va y avoir des six mais il va
repasser avec la tour derrière il va
faire des échecs
je ne va pas laisser le roi s'installer
et ça c'est nul théorique c'est à dire
trois dernières parties de contribuer en
sait elle devait être
c'était une nulle théorique en fait
valve finale roi puis mon tour contre
roye tour cette finale c'est une franche
rigolade ou en discute de comment on va
faire échec et mat et puis en fait ils
étaient sous notre nez c'était marrant à
t'arrêtes tu peux faire mater bien ce
que je me disais comment aux mathes déjà
assez trop dur de moteur ah mais attends
donc ouais donc toujours en
convalescence
ça va être ça va être chaud jusqu'au
bout à mon avis même si cardiaque il
reprend deux points tu voit lui sa
petite baisse de régime en bullet ça
peut aller vite un second but l'être
quand tu baisses de régime
tata trois minutes de déconcentration tu
as perdu deux parties quoi ça va ça va
très très vite en bus latine et du coup
tu sais ce que tu vas suivre le match de
demain soir ce qui est un deuxième match
demain soir on suit avec fabien est ce
que tu nous regardera 5 heures 19 heures
si je suis pas sur world of warcraft ou
alors à la rigueur les deux en même
temps je vous écouterai en font ça à
faire progresser quoi tu vas fou genre
voire des échecs et huard que tu va de
nouveau bien jouer quoi tu vas tu va
remonter d'ailleurs en parlant de
progresser c'était penser qu'ils
disaient dans la première vidéo que j'ai
fait avec lui que lui a regardé beaucoup
alors un peu plus son bagad matin voilà
galles matin voilà et après qu'il ait
dit ça dans les commentaires on avait
peint qui disait ah ouais c'est pas du
tout la bonne personne à regarder si tu
veux progresser parce qu'apparemment il
n'explique pas les coûts débutant en
fait il explique que les coûts très pro
vraiment fan nan mais j'aime pas trop
bas non mais c'est pas mal ce qui fait
enfin mais bon comme pagode motors pas
trop mais bon pourquoi c'est très
superficielle à plein d'un bonus
violemment de ce que j'ai compris
ouais c'est celui qui a le plus
d'abonnés je pense mais tu sais quantité
veut pas dire qualité un bon sens et sur
you tube de méritocratie sorel mais non
mais c'est bien ce qui fait enfin je
veux pas faire de mal parce qu'en fait
je pense je pense que ce qui fait c'est
bien si tu veux dans un sens mais disons
que pour moi ça regardable donc du coup
je ne peux pas avoir un jugement
pourquoi c'est un roc un regard d'homme
c'est hyper superficielles en fait si
par exemple ils analysent des partis que
j'ai aussi analyser ce qu'il raconte
c'est c'est pas faux c'est juste que
c'est très incomplet
comment ça se fait qu'il ait autant de
bonheur n'a pas qu'ils ont en fait c'est
simplifier à fond en fait il fait un
truc très simple
et du coup c'est normal en fait par
exemple pour pour bruce la chaîne de la
gamme à tort elle est beaucoup mieux que
la mienne je pense moi c'est trop
compliqué ce que je fais et du coup le
staff pour deux buts en avait quand même
en ouais mais bon les gens en général
enfin c'est un peu comme tout fait si tu
as fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de trucs pour les joueurs plus
forts si tu fais une série pour
débutants en fait les gens ils vont même
pas être au courant parce qu'ils vont
ils vont être un peu comment dire noyer
où ils vont avoir l'image d'une chaîne
très pro en fait c'est le fait que des
choses compliquées donc quand tu fais
des choses plus simples moins regarder
c'est normal et haga le matin lui ce
qu'il fait c'est ce qui fait des vidéos
très simple où ils n'expliquent pas trop
pas profondément et il simplifie
beaucoup la réalité pour ce soit simple
à comprendre en fait mais en réalité
c'est pas vraiment mais c'est pas mal si
tu veux mais sais tu vois c'est
difficile d'être objectif sur une chaîne
comme ça quand tu es pro car ce que je
veux dire tom palmer
t'as pas le même avis et du coup de main
on ya moi si tu veux c'est très mauvais
mais je comprends que ça puisse plaire
donc c'est pour ça que je veux pas dire
que c'est très mauvais parce que c'est
de mon oeil à moi de professionnels moi
aussi je regarde les chaînes de
vulgarisation qui sont hyper simpliste
un pro il va te faire pareil en fait
mais donc ccc c'est pas mal mais bon là
il ya eu un petit clash en plus avec la
cad matin y'a pas longtemps là encore ce
qu'il a utilisé des photos d'un tournoi
d'échecs mais tout clash avec tous les
joueurs de champ mais c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi c'est lui avec le tourin
d'échec de saint louis
parce qu'il a utilisé leurs photos en
gros sans droits d'auteur ils ont voulu
strikes and chaîne et du coup il a
renvoyé sa communauté dessus pour pour
pas se faire strike en fait qui ont mis
des pousses rouge et des machins de
partout des deux hommes sortent sur le
dira il ya même un joueur hyper connu ce
vide l'air qui est un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde sait que l'achat avec
lui qui apprécie aussi pris sa
communauté sur la gueule dont du coup il
s'est excusé faron c'était c'était
épique
c'était il ya une semaine de sa donc
rester juste part en campagne puisque
comme on a parlé des clash avant et tu
as parlé de ça mais oui fascinant sa
chaîne en fait elle est pâle et pas mal
franchement pour pour pour boussou pour
toi c'est plus facile de regarder sa
chaîne que la mienne par exemple
honnêtement enfants sont en anglais oui
c'est en anglais mais je peux déjà vous
français j'ai du mal à suivre alors en
anglais et pour le petit clash entre
animateurs et et ce vide leur faut que
vous alliez faut que vous alliez sur
twitter et chercher de twitter 2
2 l'air et du coup vous trouverez tout
un tas de messages et en revanche pour
le truc avec la chaîne en fait il n'a
pas vraiment classe et la chaîne il a
fait une vidéo à ce genre ouais je fais
beaucoup de bien pour les échecs et tous
genres le club de saint-louis veulent me
strike et ou alors qu'il entame strike
alors que franchement il aurait pu je
crois mais mais le truc c'est qu'en fait
il a carrément l'umih le nom du mail
avec le nom de la personne qui a envoyé
le mail avec la menace de strike et du
coup la personne s'est pris plein de
mails d'insultés dans la gueule en fait
c'est une histoire un peu sombre c'est
une grenade
tous ces drames à que je vote non mais
là c'était pas cool ne fait pas faute et
limeil de la personne et tout et qu'elle
se fasse insulter tous et c'est pas très
sympa quoi de rennes du futur est ce que
tu es sur check points comme à ben sol
oui je suis sur check point com
c'est absolument si tu veux ma ajouté ab
solitaire2a un problème de chèques
soluble et tu rajoutes un out de but tu
ajoutes en arabe et après ça s qui n'ont
le chat le mais ils étaient publiques
donc il pouvait il pouvait le partage
est comme ça mais on va dire qu'il était
publique sur le sur le site de saint
louis en fait et aussi de saint-louis
fond c'est pas moi ils ont peut-être sur
ce mail il aurait eu 10 vu quoi donc il
ya personne qui allait écrire mais en
mettant le mail le public sur une vidéo
qui fait 150 millions en floutant palais
les non pas de chercher à masquer la
personne se prennent des mails dans la
gueule et se passe on peut insulter à
mon avis personnellement alors on a dit
fox en comparaison c'est comme noces
bonne et sciences for all d'un côté de
la rigueur et de l'autre à
l'accessibilité
comme le dit si bien david en ta vidéo
si on se frôle faut s'accrocher en
[ __ ] c'est drôle avec science frôle
parce que il fait des vidéos un qui dit
accessible à tous
et puis à côté il fait les vidéos
vraiment trash ou là il faut faire là
dessus que poursuivre quoi
et même dans ces vidéos accessibles
c'est faut s'accrocher un [ __ ] c'est
trop bien que c'est le vulgarisateur qui
va vraiment dans le plus le fond des
choses je dirais le vulgarisateur le
moins accessible quoi alors que la
bulgarie thater la base ça doit être
accessible mais juste pas pour dire
qu'il garry ce mal mais après du coup
quand à des niveaux différents de
vulgarisation et lui je pense que au
niveau français c'est celui où faut le
plus s'accrocher quoi mais ça permet
vraiment de rentrer dans le fond des
choses pour le co ouais
après c'est pas mal parce que quand même
sur youtube ya quand même beaucoup de
vulgarisation de base c'est pas mal lors
des chaînes comme ça qu'ils vont plus
loin que ça permet d'avoir ça fait du
coup il a un public assez de niche tu
vois pas ce que c'est un mec qui raja
mais qui rate jamais jusqu'à un million
d'abonnés je pense ouais il s'en fout
dans ces vidéos accord il faut au moins
avoir mode su que tu vois poursuivre ce
qui bouge à regarder juste pour pourvoir
tu vois gens ne regardent et 2 3 c'est
du chinois quand c'est un gérard
comprends rien du tout je ris je connais
la chaîne de noms mais je
je regardais pas spécialement après en
ce moment il fait une très bonne série
sur tout ce qui est moral et
l'intelligence artificielle tout ça il
travaille beaucoup avec un autre que je
suis beaucoup qui s'appelle enfin qu' un
doctorat de philosophie là c'est quoi ça
chez nous c'est un vulgarisateur de
philo je m'en veux sur sa chaîne
monsieur fille voilà c'est ça un jour je
l'interviewais en 12 questions ça
pourrait être très intéressant lui je
crois que j'ai déchiré à tomber sur ces
vidéos
je suis pas figé emmené suffit je suis
pas vraiment mais je pense que j'ai déjà
vu plusieurs de ces vidéos et du coup on
me demandait si je suivais les tchats
bras ouais je regarde de temps en temps
les de chasse bras j'aime bien ça dépend
ils ont un contenu assez inégal ils ont
du bon et du moins bon
ce qu'ils font beaucoup de vidéos il
doit faire trois quatre heures de stream
par jour donc c'est énorme
donc il ya du bon et du moins bon mais
deux chaises bras il ya des trucs
vraiment sympa ça ça dépend mais j'aime
bien les fins j'ai revu a pas longtemps
j'ai regardé un stream avec eric et je
trouvais que c'était redevenu mieux que
que dans un moment eric fait moins de
stream du coup maintenant eric en scène
c'est un mec tu pourra jeter un oeil sur
internet un mec fait des stream qui à un
moment donné on a peut-être un peu trop
fait donc il avait une petite baisse de
régime quand je regardais j'aimais - et
puis là maintenant qu'il en refait moins
lui personnellement je trouve que quand
ils stream c'est redevenu bien comme
avant quoi du coup voilà quand je
regarde de temps en temps tu avoueras
c'est cool je sais pas toi c'est comme
dans ton domaine tu vas s'ils avaient
des vidéos quoi tu aurais peut-être du
mal à suivre
bah des vidéos youtube c'était dans ton
domaine
peut-être ça t'intéresserait pas du tout
puisque tu serais beaucoup trop pointu
en fait et donc j'amène dans lequel
spécialisé moi même et non par rapport à
ton talent et tout ça lui chante au
cochon tout quoi
ton taf c'est un truc hamas et pointu
non à bas après si tu me parles de
budget de comptabilité et que tu
commences à dire des conneries oui je le
veux de comptabilité de vue utilisateur
après c'est un peu dur à imaginer mais
tu vois il c'est un truc qu'on t'a pour
l'instant je crois bien c'est une niche
quoi mais si c'était anton domaine de
compétence eu avec ta des gènes de gens
qui te font des vidéos et qui
t'expliquent le truc pour des gens qui
débutent et que toi tu as fait tu as
fait plusieurs années d'études et enfin
tu vois il m'a vite trouvé ça chiant
quoi par contre vulgarisation de
fiscalité ce serait interressant ce
en fait ce serait vraiment intéressant
pour la paix pour le haut niveau impôts
tout ça tout les trucs que tu pourrais
économiser site avait su ça ce serait
intéressant et attend une fourchette
il soigne tout ça regarde au maroc est
il va devoir sacrifier la qualité à non
ils n'attaquent la dame pardon bon du
coup on suivait pas être couverts qu'il
faut qu'on se remette à suivre on s'est
perdu quoi on a on aura le temps du pool
est pour parler de jeu de tout et à rien
d'être son propre aura rien de temps
mais c'est une partie importante en fait
parce que tu vois il reste quatre
minutes donc c'est peut-être la dernière
partie 3 + 2 si elle finit pas très
rapidement et de trois plus un pardon et
donc ok c'est paul ayah dame eu trois
échecs menace la tour dames f2 et dames
pro f 4 il vient de perdre une pièce
cardiaque il il vient de donner une
pièce absolue car yakine fini il s'est
pris une fourchette une nouvelle fois
non mais bon c'est bon en fait c'est une
très bonne nouvelle si père en plus
parce qu'au prochain tour le vainqueur
de ce match je vous contre un de mes
copains à qui ça a écrit cook d'un mec
très fort et c'est un mais pas seulement
2 m'avait parlé c'est un mes potes et
donc ça veut dire que
ça veut dire s'ils jouent contre duda
c'est la très très bonne nouvelle ce
serait une très bonne nouvelle parce que
après seydou dabakala keynes et qu'il
est plus fort que ce qui nous manque oui
non mais peut-être mais enfin je regarde
grille tout va défoncer duda c'est une
évidence et des fonds seraient pas
carrier qui raclent akin on avait un peu
peur on a parlé on n'a pas peur tu vois
on disait que c'était 50-50 mais je
pense que car yakine favori mais contre
duda a great uk pour favori enfin
cardiokine aussi là pour le coup si
carrière peuvent non messika rien qu'ils
jouent comme sa grille tout va le
défoncer au 6 mai car iachini peut-être
se réveille mais la contre duda j'ai
très confiance ce sera très bien
préparés en plus critique donc il va pas
il va pas le prendre de haut c'est sûr
connaissant en connaissant la maison
great chaud que ça va être ça va être
préparé ce match et
mais à mon avis ça peut le faire du coup
il ira en demi finale et en demi-finale
après tout peut arriver le même gagner
la compet ci a quand même dix mille
euros en jeu pour le vainqueur tu as tu
gagnes plus en plus d'argent en fait
plus tu passe deux tours plus tu gagnes
le vainqueur du match de ce soir a par
exemple gagné à peu près mille six cent
mille 600 dollars faute s'appelle ben
basât chacun ouais bah ouais c'est moi
que j'annule pas mal de livres de
biologie de biologie de de bibliographie
biographie de joueur d'échecs
enfin [ __ ] temps en tout cas de ce que
j'ai compris c'était très dur dans le
vivant ouais mais ça il fallait faire
tout le temps des parties de simultanée
à l'aveuglé qu'il y avait que ça qui
marche et que c'était une sorte de
spectacle un peu comme le cirque
il n'y a rien du tout il faisait le tour
de la france
si peu comme des pros locaux n'ont
maintenant ça paye bien mais tous les
sports
enfin les sports c'est mieux payés
qu'avant en général si tu prends le foot
par exemple bon avant il ya de l'argent
mais german ans et des sommes démesurées
en fait qui gagne quoi le foot sort
compote mais ouais mais il ya encore 30
40 ans tu vois c'était pas si c'était
pas autant en fait donc
les échecs tu vois avant c'était
vraiment la galère galère et puis
maintenant me c'est partout pareil c'est
comme le lance moment c'est lisse porte
c'est des trucs de fou ce qui se passe
là en ce moment tu as vu les sommes à
gagner là en ce moment avec les sport's
est décédé c'était des centaines de
milliers voire des millions d'euros sur
les répétitions c'est mettre le paquet
bah faut qu'on s'y mette et coûtant non
j'aime pas j'aime pas ce jeu ben je
pense qu'on sera civils en plus à
séduire les spartes avaler ce portrait
faut faire faut avoir flotte bien
accrocheur des heures sur l'ordinateur
tous les joueurs disent portes de lol
par kraft de overweight
c'est des mecs qui jouent à 8 heures par
jour ou même jeu tout en tous les
joueurs tous les personnages tout ce
qu'ils peuvent faire toutes les
possibilités toutes les combinaisons
c'est dur enfin c'est vraiment dur
d'avoir envie faut le vouloir je sais
pas
pour moi les effectifs et les échecs ça
va être encore pire je pense parce que
c'est comme si ta vie se résumer à 64
cases elle tourne plus autour de ça plus
tard je sais pas si cette partie n'en à
pas contés donc écouter à huit et demi
huit et demi
pourquoi la pompe tout cela s'est passé
en fait le temps le temps des trois
minutes et était était terminé et donc
il reste trente minutes de bull est en
plus un plus un et c'est chaud comme
jamais absolu égalité et franchement vu
la physionomie du match
ok on va dire que carrière qui n'est
quand même encore favori parce que c'est
car yakine mais honnêtement le momen le
blues à l'avantagé psychologique là je
pense que doux dallas en tout cas
physiquement il a pris le dessus et ça
m'étonnerait pas de voir la première
grosse surprise de ce pitch est sans
trois
saison c'est quelque chose quand même
s'il se pose là il faut une mini pause
mais ça va repartir incessamment sous
peu
ça va repartir très vite et je vais je
vais aller faire un petit tweet je vais
aller faire un petit tweet pour pour
dire que c'est chaud parce que c'est
chaud bas mais c'est vraiment faim tu
vois je suis étonné quoi attends je vais
faire tout dadou d'apw a décrit voyage
et duda peut créer peut créer l'exploit
de créer l'exploit face à kariat keane
et je vais te faire un petit bond à
l'est pendant ce temps là je vous prends
tout sûr de chasse points comme les gens
du front tout le monde allait ajouter
moi absolue bhl je vous prends tous faut
que jour il faut que j'augmente mon
allez olla armes et u20 progrès là ce
soir tu a progressé en fait je vous fais
une bulle est là chacun allez on et 79,6
en 19 minutes et 619 c'est pas mal hein
c'est pas mal on est ce qui est ce qui
est bien c'est surtout si on est au
dessus des espagnols et des portugais
en fait c'est souvent comme ça qu'on
compare on compare entre les longues
souvent à tchatche.com après pour voir
plus j'ai plus d'amis sur check point
comme que sont facebook
alors on est peut-être le times il fait
1110 a mis sur mon profil jobs.com vous
est-ce que tu dois commencer à faire que
dès que des échecs sur ta chaîne
principale en fait tu te fais plus que
ça il y en avait beaucoup qui m'ont dit
mais pourquoi tu m'épates partie
d'échecs sur ta chaîne principale
vous vous rendez pas compte
non mais c'est vrai que c'est dommage ça
foudre est complètement le truc c'était
par sa partie contre y pense et aurait
pu mais c'est incroyable parce que les
participants encontre y penser c'est
vraiment des parties des vidéos bonus tu
vois qu'on a fait en plus comme ça à
l'arraché ballon
de vue que ensemble elles ont fait plus
de vue que l'interview et que en tout
seules certaines vidéos avec enfin une
partie seulement a fait plus de vue que
d'autres interviews par exemple avec le
magicjack coude et ricains de saâd ya un
crime n'est donc ça veut dire que c'est
pas si mal
non mais c'est l'algorithme et youtube
je vois un coup s'est il fait un truc de
dingue je sais pas pourquoi cette vidéo
là ont superbement bien marché ça a
battu à tous les records les parties de
chasse young boys à lennon mais c'est
bien c'est cool alors qu on fait de la
merde faisais pas je m'en fous ça me
rapporte désabonner donc automatiquement
je suis heureux moi je pense que oui
indirectement oui c'est sûr quant au
temps que les échecs gagnera en
popularité sur youtube de quelques
manières que ce soit toi tu gagneras des
abonnés par dessus c'est au mois ou
quelqu'un d'autre en fait tu sais que
j'étais allé faire le switch to you got
what you mieux référencées au niveau des
échecs sur youtube france mais je suis
allé faire le tweet du tour à paris
s'était genre de rencontre c'était
intéressant et en fait les mecs ils
expliquer un peu comment ça marche et le
marketing le machin le truc comment
avoir plus de following est en fait il
est expliqué un truc c'est que plus il
ya de gens dans ton domaine facilité
déjà un streamer à la cité pour les
partenaires twitch en fait expliqué que
plus tad gens qui sont dans ton domaine
qui font des vidéos dans ton domaine
si si toi tu as déjà une grosse chaîne
en fait ça te rapporte des abonnés en
fait plus à des gens qui en font plus
attrapeurs d'abonnés à toi bah ouais non
mais c'est normal avec les
recommandations tout ça en fait il est
vrai ça marche comme ça parce que les
gens pètent plus ta non plus envie de
regarder parce que les gens ils vont où
il ya du monde
naturellement chez de masse c'est
l'effet menacé en fait j'ai dû tout
fouillé argent qui est encore plus de
confiance mais c'est le gros problème au
sénat bah oui c'est du coup tu en as ils
ont plein d'abonnés sans raison valable
tu vois oui oui c'est bien c'est comme
sur twitter aussi parfois que tu as un
mec qui te re tweet ou qui tu parles tu
vas sur son profil il a je sais pas de
100000 un follower
ah bon qui ça peut bien être parfois
c'est un random tu vois mais je suis sûr
qu'il y en a ils tombent sur son profil
il le faut l'eau sans forcément le
connaître mais juste parce qu'il a plein
de photos au cas où ces mais c'est
pareil dans tous les domaines ce cas
votre regard la restauration s'étaient
de restaurant à côté du monde à personne
en effet tu dois bien connaître ça tu me
disait ton père qui est restaurateur oui
le monde attire le monde en fait c'est
surtout quand les restos c'est clair du
coup à bulles atteint leur but let's
c'est vrai que compliquée à jarry jamais
à suivre ces trucs là il faut que tu
suives le spectacle plutôt tu vas faut
suivre le flot de coûts c'est comme de
la musique en fait c'est tu vois c'est
c'est du rap
ce serait drôle qui mettent des notes de
musique sur chaque case jouer tu vois
des notes différentes spécifique
africa's ce sens après de belles
mélodies
ça serait ça peut être une idée
d'ailleurs peut-être dans le chatt ya
des gens qui vont être chauds pour pour
faire un plugin parce qu'il ya des gens
qui font des plugins comme ça a dit ce
qu'ils avaient fait ça avec le nombre pi
pour chaque nombreuses les mines notes
et ça avait fait une super belle mélodie
en fait ça m'étonne pas ça m'étonne pas
manquer qui est favori alors seul on se
mouille allez on dit on dit qu'un truc
on l'a la fougue et à la fougue alors
qu'ils l'emportent sur sur les quinze
kilos de perdus de karuïa keane moi je
n'ai toujours pas changé je suis
toujours pouvoir le même sujet du renvoi
en mode fuchs et des fougueux l'offre la
fougue de la jeunesse n'attend pas car
il ya trente minutes alors attends faut
que je mette à bien le chrono pour qu'on
les ok il reste 28 minutes 50
tu vois cette année je t'avais promis un
les matchs sont un peu plus court mais
on aura quand même trois heures temps
pourquoi à 3h30 ce soir on a mis 3h15 et
dernière fois écoute j'en sais rien mais
tout de même on approchera pas des
quatre heures comme on avait fait mieux
plus de pauses cette fois ci c'est pour
ça un moment de y ait une déconnexion
entre les deux entre les deux matches on
est un petit temps d'arrêt donc on a
perdu 100 personnes bah ils sont partis
durant et qu'il y ait du monde du coup
il s'en va rester pendant la pause
ou peut-être on a perdu la première page
fait à un moment donné de 7 en première
page switch et ça c était retombé en
deuxième temps
m ça marche beaucoup comme ça du coup
cette partie tu as c'est toujours la
même structure depuis on en a on en a vu
un des comme ça
absolue avec les cations compte trois là
ouais ça me dit quelque chose naturelle
ça c'est un truc que tu as retenu pour
reporter parti à toi quand tu vois cette
structure de pions du coup tu tu sauras
que c'est plus difficile de faire un
pion passé quand tu as des pions doublé
bateaux sont j'évite toujours d'avoir
deux pions doublé clairement j'essaie de
le faire pour l'adversaire en tout cas
ça excès mais c'est un adversaire que si
c'est toi qui les a du coup il reste 20
secondes pour chaque joueur mais une
seconde de rage ou là tu peux pas
pousser b4 pour le moment pascal pions
c4 qui tomberait la tour qui met ainsi
l'option eps vii le roi qui se bat pour
plus être en face de la tour et il va
envoyer le pion à je regarde dangereux
criminels c'est reparti quoi donc et
d'un coup il venir angers 5 avec le
cavalier qui est prescrit à faire tout
rage 2 ou pas si ça fait leur en a eu
deux carlina monnaie car les kin qui est
mieux là avec les noirs ils comment ça
commence à avancer mais les blancs
voient le contre je regarde pas le pion
h qui va filer pas le droit qui vient se
mettre en a je suis devant pour le
bloquer c'est beau hein en plus c'est
une seconde devant plus c'est ça à
chaque coup physiquement enfin c'est
possible de réfléchir une seconde est de
jouer une seconde
ouais faut prendre sa défense auprès
mouvant fait un foutu c'est généralement
le coup tu vas jouer a toujours prévu
quoi donc sûr de ce que l'autre joue
quoi c'est de passer affirme à foisches
4 x 4 x 4 et 6 matches qui arrivent
c'est fini c'est fini c'est fini
il s'est fait piéger car yakine il s'est
pris le piège
duda qui prend les devants ap sol do do
qu'imad lahoud à qui même incroyable
franchement tu nous aurait dit ça après
une heure de jeu on t'aurait enfin on
aurait dit non c'est ça n'arrivera pas
quoi est mon favori gagnant ouais écoute
ce serait sympa de voir ça ce serait
très sympa de voir ça tout cas moi je
suis vraiment content de voir une
surprise j'en connais un qui va aller au
goulag
ce serait une grosse déception pour lui
un c'est sûr que c'est sûr que là une
défaite contre contre 12 da c'est quand
même une grosse contre-performance
surtout dans ce format où il ya
normalement jamais de surprise mais bon
faut jamais dire jamais et on dit qu'il
ya 1 0 pour l'allemagne
attends je vais lui ouvrir la porte à
mon chien du plan flou qui n'en fait
voir ça à tanger vérifier l'information
est ce qu'il ya vraiment 1 0 pour
l'allemagne c'est quand même important
y at il vraiment ce surnom urbita
l'instant moi j'ai toujours écrit 1 0900
c'était qu il ya toujours 0 0
c'est tellement objets tout le temps
vérifier les informations et tous ces
trolls c'est vraiment biais de sa hâte
avant très flou qui quittent d'ailleurs
de kim là non pas moi il est trop mignon
et il est taillé adultes maintenant
instant tendresse cependant avec des
chèques
oui la taille adulte le bébé il fait la
sar pris à il est assez grand cayman kg
il ya des chats chez moi ray enfin les
choix du voisin surtout je suis
allergique aux chats et chat du voisin
là l'autre jour c'était quand c'est
avant-hier je suis descendu ouvrir la
porte à un copain et
il avait son chien c'était un peu
problématique avec le chat du voisin il
voulait pas le laisser entrer quoi il
s'est mis devant et dès qu'ils voient et
le chien qui s'approchait tu sentais
qu'il attaquait quoi il faisait des
petits bruits bizarres des petits ch un
peu mais pas vraiment chaud c'était un
peu talent est un peu space quoi moi flo
qui fait dès qu'un nouveau choc qui
croisent leur fait des bisous après ça
dépend si chat c'est le chat dessine lui
mettre un coup de griffe ou pas quoi
mais regarde il va encore gagner duda en
fait assez incroyable et azilal avantage
psychologique très il est cassé car
l'équipe a mais non mais il est vraiment
4g casser mentalement la vergari la plus
tant il est mal je vais écrire à vlad il
va être content c'est l'entraîneur de
green tune
je vais lui dire de regarder la fin du
match je vais écrire
immédiatement je vais y écrire cardiaque
en train de se faire défoncer cariat qui
est en train de perdre lui écrire de
perdre contre 12 il va être content si
permet à ces foutus là il ya la tour qui
on va il ya les deux pions passé à la
fin tu vois là où ils ont aidé à main
ses affaires ses 3 et puis va pousser
encore gagné deux points d'écart pas de
fond sans ouais mais c'est je pensais
vraiment physique là c'est ça veut pas
s'expliquer autrement puisque karine il
fait trop de fautes il a donné des
pièces en inde où il reste 20 minutes 1
est ce qu'il va réussir à ceux à se
transcender à se mettre à 100 % et à
l'emporter
rien n'est moins sûr ce serait beau que
ça allait en prolongation en cas
d'égalité il ya un genre de tirs au but
quoi
mais bon et ce grâce kouassi égalitaire
je crois qu'il rejoue trois parties une
de cinq plus un une deux trois plus sain
et une de 1 plus 1 et s'il ya toujours
égalité ça se décide sur une partie 2 1
puis 5
le gagnant gagne le match prolifique
turquie des tirs au but à la presse
qu'il va y avoir encore une merde damas
six échecs bobby fischer qui suit
souvent je suis beaucoup de live il me
semble que je le vois chaque fois que tu
te dois alors est ce qui suit ta chaine
du coup est-ce que tu suis la chaîne
d'absolut fischer c'est un jeune il est
jeune il est très sympa alors on n'y a
plus d'égalité possible s'ils refont
trois parties après une égalité y en a
un qui aura gagné deux fois et l'autre
une haie mais il faut avoir une victoire
chacun et une nulle aussi il ne suis pas
ta chaine ovi store en fait c'est pas si
sympa que sakharov
je rigole 300 bobby charlton
placez vos histoires 2 tu vois ces cinq
jours de suite quoi le pis donc cette
partie tendue cette partie tendue par
une de madame est toujours la même
structure de pions un marron il a fait
que des bandes des changes à l'espagnol
duda ta parisienne perfidie de
l'interview de joueur du grenier t il
très intéressante série fait regarder
aussi cette vidéo c'est incroyable a
fait un million huit cent mille vue ice
et joueur du grenier après un essai
dingue 1 million 800 mille vu une vidéo
qui dure trois heures
deux mecs sur un canapé un million huit
cent mille bus a laissé jdg après mais
même même ses débuts même gdg fait pas
ce nombre de vues sur certaines de ces
vies
officiel l'algorithme a pété un câble
sur cette vidéo là je pense que ces
systèmes adresse avec l'algorithme ça
joue tellement des bandes jdg c'est
peut-être la meilleure chaîne youtube de
gaming
enfin pour moi en tout cas sur youtube
c'est pas du jdg après enfin un petit
peu sur sa chaîne secondaire mais sur sa
chaîne principale c'est plus dur review
comic con way il est drôle il est
marrant je sais pas j'aime bien son
montage aussi que ces vidéos sont
dynamiques mais pas trop ce pas forcé
pas de dynamisme force et tu vois ce que
je veux dire ouais je me fonds s'agit
déjà de façon assez impressionnant il
était complètement gagnant avec les
noirs il vient de rater une fourchette
qua non lui le foot c'est impressionnant
c'est incroyable ans mais sympa parce
que ces décès en fait une nouvelle fois
il a complètement dominé la partie
il s'est retrouvé très bien et il laisse
traîner un truc en un coup et mme alors
est-ce qu'il est foutu jettent est
exagéré mais son avantage s'est réduit
comme peau de chagrin
enfin vous incroyable et en plus tu as a
fait couler beaucoup de temps c'est des
parties très longues et donc il ya de
moins en moins de temps pour remonter
mais ok ça reste tendu parce qu'il ya
encore un dangereux criminel qui n'est
pas facile à arrêter
ok va revenir ici pour l'arrêter mais il
va fait rage 2 ça va échanger inquiets
mais il va récupérer un pion rockets
mais peut-être qu'il va gagner carrier
qui en réalité n'en puisque c'est le
pion à il va faire cavalier c'est 3b de
roi ok ça à faire nul c'est une ultime
rick quand il te reste un pion comme ça
et que
et que t'as pas le fou de la bonne
couleur ok mais c'est une occasion de
perdue pour car yakine une nouvelle pour
monter tavaux butscher de kindi fennecs
carrière kin one en essaim hallucinant
franchement d'être payés ouais je sais
je sais pas ce qu'il fait mais c'est
hallucinant c'est hallucinant chaque
essai 5 je pense il va reprendre du
monde et voilà c'est ça il va se donner
la casse des 4 mai car et à qui on avait
parlé avec fabien et tous qu'on avait
parlé du speech s ils faisaient faillite
fait pas il faisait partie des grands
avec nakamura c'était les deux grands
favoris du tournoi donc c'est se fait
éliminer dès le premier tour
c'est vraiment un séisme quoi maximy le
jeu quand le maximum je sais pas contest
qui joue son quart de finale mais il a
passé le premier tour assez
tranquillement contre dominguez qui
était un bon joueur mais bien moins fort
et il va jouer au prochain tour contre
hikaru nakamura dont ta tête entendu
parler bon on a vu comment tu es au sort
et il avait gagné le match rien a
commenté
ouais je t'avais dit que c'était le sur
internet c'est un peu le pape
c'est un peu le joueur du grenier des
échecs sur internet pas au niveau des
vidéos mais au niveau du niveau de jeu
bon là ce qui se passe tu vois c'est que
les noirs ils veulent capitaliser sur ce
pion mais les blancs les les blancs sont
beaucoup mieux je pense
il ya ça qui va se faire attaquer il ya
des moyens d'attaquer le roi une
nouvelle fois à kariat king qui dominent
la partie mais bon j'ai un prénom qui
domine toutes les parties les premiers
matches où il a joué contre la plus
jouable la caméra joue au premier tour
contre la joueuse numéro un mondial
l'après ford joueuses et il a battu 28
av
25 4 2 ou 1 25 à 3 quelque chose comme
ça un massacre bon temps là non ouais ça
finit un peu plus tard ça devait finir à
22h
ça va finir vers 22h20 22h05 22h15 et
une petite pause au début les parties
sont mal ça a commencé un peu retard
déjà ça commençait à 5
il ya eu cinq minutes de pause
supplémentaire au moment on n'a pas
compris ce qu'il foutait
et ça a du mal se goupiller donc c'est
le match qui va finir le plus tard sa
tombe ses choix que les matches il y
avait 5o elle est là c'est fini les
matches qui se finissent tard ça tombe
sur toi en fait je pense jeune âge à
chaque fois qu'on vous recommande de
trucs
ils ont toujours une heure de plus voilà
il reste il reste 15 minutes en finir
vers 22h10 son égard en moyenne ça va
faire 20 me depuis 6 heures et cinq
minutes à 5 minutes là et puis après un
suivant comment ça se goupille alors
mais là c'est complètement gagnant et à
une pièce de plus pour car yakine mais
duda qui continue à jouer parce qu'il
veut dans ma vie veut laisser tourner un
peu le temps pour qu'ils aient moins
deux parties
en fait vu que c'est toi qui commande je
pense qu'il va garder des partages ce
soir pour que ça frise encore plus tard
ce feu
ça tombe sur toi mais là si si si si car
y'a qui ne gagnent pas celle-là je sais
pas ce qu'il faut faire parce que là
c'est complètement complètement foutu ça
c'est pas mal ça aussi à retenir portait
partie quand un pion passé comme ça tu
bloques la tour il ya bon il reste douze
minutes 50 1 point d'écart la fougue
ça fait reprendre par l'expérience quoi
tu étendue à tanger créa bla du envoie
le lien il va venir suivre le match
vachement était tout le temps dépassée
en fait y avait but d'être je te sens
complètement
bon je fais de suse me tais hypnotisé
par le truculent quelque part en fait
tout le temps que je regarde un
mouvement que j'essaie de comprendre
pourquoi il a joué ce mouvement c'en est
déjà passé dix de plus tu vois tu
essayes de comprendre tu regarde
vraiment ça comme un tu vois comme un
comme un truc qui s'enchaînent quoi
ouais bah dans ce cas là je vois juste
des figures de couleur bouger sur des 15
quand tu fais un petit peu comme ma
maman qui regardent peut-être qu'ils
essayent de sentir le regard des masses
man 2 pièces plutôt bien il ya beaucoup
de pièces par de ce côté là où elle est
c'est de sentir si les pièces s'avancer
rage
regardez là ou pas well et leurs gardes
en plus je les trouvais quoi alors elle
à oxo surtout fritsch la fin pinceau sur
twitter ouah à suivre la chaîne
donc du coup à mon avis elles l'ont
regardé les masses man 2 pièces non mais
elle aime bien quand ses pensées
commenté avec toi elle dit que c'est
plus facile à comprendre du coup
vraiment comprendre ce qui se passe
parce que sinon surtout qu'on parle pas
d'échec à chaque fois on a parlé plus
des cher qu'aujourd'hui que la dernière
fois qu'on a commenté avec mathieu avec
femme je crois le mag on tenait le match
n'était pas très intéressant on est
parti on a parlé de tout et de rien et
je couche opaque
je crois pas que mes parler trop
d'échecs mais c'était le match le moins
intéressant qu'on est suivi de
l'histoire des speechs as a joué
tellement mal c'était une horreur les
joueurs étaient pas en forme donc
position tu vois assez symétrique mais
les noirs ils sont pas mal parce qu'ils
ont cavaliers le fou tu vois qu'ils
peuvent faire une attaque sur le roi
mais d'un autre côté les blancs ils
neutralisent bien cette attaque avec le
fou qui protège et du coup ils veulent
jouer la contre attaque sur le pion ses
6 10 ans de schalke va doit être dégoûté
le temps que je dise que duda gagne il
s'est fait égaliser
enfin toujours ouais mais bon c'est la
poisse quoi c'est la poisse bon d'ouzaï
lampions de plus il a réussi à gagner le
pion et maintenant il va envoyer son
dangereux criminels
ok c'est chantant j'écris un trip c'est
un petit message et on est reparti
d'ailleurs la semaine prochaine les mecs
on suivra notamment avec vlad bien sûr
tous avec fabien le retour de gary
kasparov qui jouera un match
d'exhibition contre topalov ce sera à
les 11 12 13 à partir de 20h sur twitter
là il faut vraiment qu'ils essayent d'y
aller j'ai pas qu'il fasse tour g8 et
qui tente d'abuser 4 qui t'en fous qui
m'attend fait il n'a pas le choix
mais le fou est fort tu vois il contrôle
beaucoup de casse proche du roi dame
prend 1,5 et d'un point f4 aïe aïe aïe
car les kings qui a encore donné une
pièce en un coup non il n'était pas très